ladies and gentlemen it is the night you
have all been waiting for Donald Trump
is set to announce he will be running
for the president of the United States
2024. it'll be happening tonight he is
going to be live streaming around 9pm so
we will be watching and hanging out and
we will ABS we will be uh showing to the
best of our abilities whatever uh his
speech is obviously with our commentary
there's some overlap so keep that in
mind it might get hard to hear sometimes
but uh we'll be watching we'll be
talking about his announcement and uh
discussing politics
um as it pertains to this major
announcement now it is being confirmed
by NBC news that a longtime Trump
advisor has confirmed to them Trump will
announce he is running some people
thought maybe that wasn't the case
everyone kind of thought yeah he's going
to announce and it is going to be
spectacular I have to imagine Trump is
going to make this one a grand ceremony
a grand entrance so this should be
particularly fun and exciting
but in the news world we got a couple
crazy stories Article 4 has been invoked
by Poland they are convening ambassadors
from various NATO countries into Poland
talk about how to respond to what is
being reported as a Russian missile
strike hitting polish territory we don't
know that's the case
some have said that it may actually have
been anti-uh anti-air missiles I believe
Ukrainian that backfired and then fell
from the sky and slammed into the ground
or something but we're not entirely sure
some said it appeared that these were
Russian strike on Railways which sounds
like it may be them trying to disrupt
supply lines
again
not a lot confirmed the next story is
just uh it's so much fun and it was a
story I wanted to cover earlier but then
you know World War III is kicking off
and I can't Elon Musk is firing more
woke employees just with without regard
for their feelings just posting on
Twitter
and he even invited invited our good
friends ligma and Johnson to Twitter HQ
and took a photo with him so uh I think
that's particularly funny so that'll be
fun to talk about and then of course
around 9pm eastern time so about one
hour Donald Trump is is going to start
his his announcement and we'll have that
playing and so we'll check all that
stuff out before we get started my
friends head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and download and
pick up virtual Shield a virtual private
network service this is a basic layer of
security for you as you browse the web
so if you don't want creepy hackers
governments or corporations spying on
your data this provides a basic layer of
security for you as you browse the web
it also has the edit bonus of if there's
some kind of weird block on your
internet that shouldn't be there that's
preventing you from watching TV shows or
asking other content this will help you
bypass those things so check out virtual
Shield over at surfinginternetsafe.com
they've got uh it's 72 percent off a
Black Friday sale you get the full
identity protection with VPN plus
included social security protection and
real-time 24 7 alerts it'll protect you
and your entire family with up to one
million dollars Insurance that's amazing
ad and malware blocking that runs
continuously you can stream your
favorite TV shows and movies with
premium streaming which I think is is
actually really important especially
vpns you know you want to make sure you
have the fastest possible option if you
want to stream stuff priority customer
support you can hide your IP address
anytime fight censorship from your own
home by accessing their Global Network
with military grade encryption at the
touch of a button and you get unlimited
devices browse on your phone and laptop
simultaneously again head over to
servinginternetsafe.com this is the
first sponsor that we've ever had so
we're big fans we're eternally grateful
for their support don't give money to
people who hate you give your money to
to people who have been supporting the
work that's people you like have been
doing and that I'll put it this way
virtual Shield knows who you are they
like you they that that's why they
sponsor this show they really do want
your business so support good businesses
and don't forget to head over to
timcast.com
and click that join us button become a
member to get access to our members only
show now considering
Donald Trump will be speaking and
presenting we don't know how long this
will go if it does go long we likely
will not have the uncensored members
only show tonight because we might end
up just staying live to watch Donald
Trump speak we will see but we are
launching this new cool thing where if
you are a member and you comment on
members only content once per week we're
going to choose five people we're going
to hit you up and say hey we're going to
send you something cool from the set of
the show that uh you know it's just a
cool little knick-knack like we have
these balloons from when Luke was
stuffing a shirt with with you know fake
gazangas and then we've got uh real
bazungus sorry bazungus and then we've
got uh obviously those little posts that
Milo made we'll be we'll be contacting
people and sending those out this week
so uh if that's something you're into
then uh then comment and we look forward
to it smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this as well as some really uh some
other really interesting stuff there's a
big lawsuit going on is Daniel Miller
would you like to introduce yourself yes
I'm uh Daniel Miller president of the
Texas Nationals movement and I think as
the bio tells me as everyone does I'm
the father of the modern texit movement
so that's a lot of pressure I'm not
gonna lie you basically want Texas to
become its own country well absolutely
yeah I mean if if anyone's familiar with
brexit then they will understand Texan
where Texas becomes a self-governing
independent nation again
well right on that'll basically plus you
guys got this lawsuit against the
federal government I believe well we're
suing meta uh we're doing meta sorry
yeah we're suing Facebook uh because
Facebook we've had a long battle with
Facebook regarding censorship right I
mean they've they've done anything you
could imagine they were uh you know as
far as censorship goes they were doing
to us first
uh and uh here recently they decided
that they wanted to prevent people from
posting uh links to texasnow.org right
which is the main page that we have all
of the Texas questions and and this was
a new one uh they said it violates
Community standards says that it's uh
you know against uh where they keep
people from posting uh content about
organizations that incite violence or
whatever which is completely the
opposite of what we're about uh and so
what we did was we finally had our fill
look you know Facebook has been doing
this to us for years you know them
Amazon Twitter all of them but Facebook
we were up to here yeah they want to
control the narrative and so we just
said hey we're going after them so we'll
get into that that's very interesting so
uh should be fun thanks for joining us
of course absolutely we got to Lou
gradkowski hanging out text it I like it
I really like it a lot I like that you
like it yeah my name is lucrative here
we are changed at Oregon some of you
guys are a little perturbed to put me a
little mad at me because I don't like
your favorite politician but you should
know I don't like any politician I
believe Wars
no I'm critical of DeSantis as well I'm
critical of all the politicians which
everyone should be but I believe Wars
murder taxation is theft police are
gangs and politicians or criminals if
you're with me on that you could support
me and my efforts here by getting the
shirt that says that on the best
politicalshirts.com and I said many
times to Santos again not a perfect
candidate no one's perfect and there are
some things that we could be critical of
a mom just like we should be critical of
everyone
uh hi everyone Ian crossing here Daniel
you uh have a book as well I don't think
we've talked about that yet but it's
actually called texit it is and is that
something some people can get somewhere
we'll talk about it near the end we'll
talk about the book later in the show
and then yeah
aim people towards it thank you thanks
for coming man uh what's up everybody
I'm filling in again today for search uh
I'm really excited let's go let's get
going his name is Kellen my name is
Kellen that's right all right so uh we
we do have the rumble player
um ready ready to go for When Donald
Trump begins his speech at 9pm we have
the story from NBC News ladies and
gentlemen it is confirmed Trump to
announce he will run for president in
2024. this is uh NBC news reporting you
want to pull that one up there you go
Trump will announce Trump has continued
to falsely assert that he won the 2020
election but that he was denied office
by rampant fraud if I'm sorry I'm kind
of I'm going to say this right away if
Donald Trump launches his 2024 campaign
announcement off of 2022 complaints
about fraud I think he's gonna spiral
Crash and Burn I I know a lot of people
have people have reached out to me and
said Tim if Trump doesn't address this
stuff it won't get resolved and that may
be
but um I think that it is too esoteric
and it is confusing for younger voters I
think it is it isn't Trump's Revenge
Trump's retribution Trump 2020 is not
the message we need I think Trump needs
to come out and say Biden screwed you
over and you all know it let me fix it
yeah I mean the American people are
going through a lot of problems right
now especially financially especially
when it comes to our foreign policy
especially when it comes to having a
leader that can't even read his own
notes at the G20 and has to go take a
nap and not meet with the foreign
delegations uh that are meeting at this
prestigious dinner not prestigious but
you know what I mean here uh if he's
going to be smart here he's going to be
talking about America's problems how he
could solve it the future how his
presidency would look like how he would
be different than he was before but if
he does focus on the past I do think
he's going to be losing a lot of people
the independent is reporting that he's
trying to convince Ivanka and Jared to
join him on this announcement so it's
going to be interesting to see who
stands behind him who's there Candace
Owens made some very interesting
statements a couple days ago saying
saying that Trump now has someone around
him that's trying to push away the
populist based trying to push away
Candace herself away from Donald Trump
so it's going to be interesting who's
there what he's going to be saying and
essentially what are going to be his
plans hopefully that he's going to be
talking about and not talking about the
past yeah I agree I think if he's going
to come out and complain about his
feelings about what happened to him in
his election and the processes and
everything he needs to display a
solution immediately he needs to come
out and say this will help us prevent
this from happening again these free
software systems for instance voting
online on a blockchain for instance
things that are transparent voting
online on like nine different
blockchains so they can all be
referenced but I have a feeling he's
going to come out and complain and not
offer any solutions and just get the the
angry people behind him again like he
did last and if he's really smart he's
going to be talking about ballot
harvesting he's going to be talking
about mail-in ballots and also talking
about a plan to deal with all of that
along with big Tech social media
censorship which stands in the way of
Republicans ever winning any kind of
political office well look I mean people
I think I think the biggest mistake that
people on the other side of the election
Integrity issue have made is whether
whether they believe the assertions or
not they have totally ignored the
concerns that people have right
regardless of whether the route is is
true or not what they've done is instead
of saying look I get you have concerns
and this voting issue is sort of the
Cornerstone of a constitutional republic
and so we need to we need to do
everything we can to shore this up right
we go back to the Defcon report from
2019 where they had voting Village and
were able to hack all those machines
right but no one ever addresses concerns
Defcon the hacker convention right the
hacker convention right so they showed
that electronic voting machines are
susceptible and so instead of addressing
those issues and saying okay look we get
it every machine and voter in the voter
Village got hacked what they did was
they decided to marginalize and
essentially tell people look if you have
any concerns about this you're just a
whack job conspiracy theorist and so you
know is that a running issue for Trump I
don't think so it's always got to be
about you know for most people about the
economy well but it has those those
issues do have to be addressed it is one
I think what we saw in the midterms
Republicans tried really hard for the
most part to focus on what the Democrats
were doing wrong and things they didn't
like or things they wanted to get rid of
CRT in schools was a big issue probably
because people saw young can succeed
but I if if you're going after the fraud
narrative
you are not explaining to people what
you want to do other than we were done
wrong and we want the system to correct
that that Injustice
and if you're coming out and just saying
hey we're going to show up our energy
policy we're going to lower you know
interest rates or or whatever we're
going to make the economy better then
you're ignoring another big problem so
it's kind of a double-edged sword ballot
harvesting is a major issue Republicans
thought they could they could Target
Target you know political and cultural
issues and that would get them a victory
without realizing the ballot harvesting
operation is intense that ballot
harvesting not fraud there is some
fraudulent ballot harvesting but in 39
States they're allowed to do it I
believe 13 states have no restrictions
whatsoever and we've even heard some
officials say that you can Harvest as
many votes as you want so long as that
person signs off that you are designated
to do so and so that is a major
disadvantage if Republicans aren't
tackling that and and focusing on either
building a ballot harvesting operation
like Democrats have then they're going
to lose if you campaign on that people
are going to say I don't know what
you're talking about so it's it's it's
difficult I understand that you know
Republicans need is a vote by drone
campaign where you designate a drone as
your Harvester it comes to your house
picks it up because no one can has the
time to drive for six hours a day from
from giant farm to giant farm we just
need drones doing it well look it's
here's the we could talk about the the
election Integrity issues and that's
obviously a big concern down in Texas I
mean we're we're all over that we're
we're still dealing right now in Harris
County largest county in Texas most
populous County in Texas uh dealing with
just an absolute abortion of an election
day right I mean we've been joking and
calling it East Maricopa County
um so you know I mean it's it's been
it's been horrible uh but you know if
we're talking about issues that are
going to motivate voters I mean I just
look look at what's motivated our base
right what has led the text at issue to
become to become the issue for 66
percent of likely voters right if Texas
was on the ballot tomorrow 66 percent of
likely voters in Texas would vote in
Texas would vote in favor and the
reasons are pretty clear number one they
believe the federal government is too
big too bloated Federal overreach right
too intrusive in their lives and and
it's the border and immigration for 15
years the border and immigration
together as an issue have polled as the
number one concern for Texas voters uh
when we see the same number of illegal
immigrants cross the border from Mexico
into Texas every month that's higher
than the number of Allied troops that
landed on the beaches of Normandy at
D-Day that is massive and and it goes
unresolved and unaddressed and so uh if
you're going to have uh look if Donald
Trump wanted to make some fans tonight
he would come out and say I'm running
for president and what I'm going to do
my number one issue is to put it on the
ballot for every state to determine
whether they want to stay in the union
or not oh geez
I thought you were going to say he was
going to come out and say build the wall
well yeah I mean maybe between you know
it was funny I was interviewed by the
New York Times one time they said do you
think that uh do you think that the
United States ought to put troops on the
river and we said absolutely let's put
them all along the Red River because
we're tired of the snowbirds coming in
the winter
um geography less than the red rivers
between us and Oklahoma so that's
another story
I went over our heads yeah sorry guys I
think it's also fair to ask is Donald
Trump going to be successful here here
is he going to win because he's facing
off against Biden who who's weak but
again is he going to deal with the
mail-in ballots ballot harvesting is he
going to be attacked by The
Establishment is the doj still going to
be going after him the Washington Post
is reporting right now that the doj is
saying that if Trump runs this is not
going to stop the justice department
criminal probe of Donald Trump so if the
justice department goes after him I see
that actually lifting him up and
actually helping him especially when it
comes to the popularity and if he's
running against a Nikki Haley a Mike
Pompeo a Mike Pence all the the Goblins
of the DC swamp that he helped enable
then I see something that's going to be
successful here if he runs against Ron
DeSantis it's going to be a tough battle
it's not going to be an easy one it's
not going to be a tough battle
necessarily one way the way I look at it
is Ron DeSantis and Trump in a primary
will be the best possible thing for
republicans and whatever the more
liberty-minded faction is because Trump
will have to find a way to contend with
desantis's popularity and success policy
wise and DeSantis will have to find a
way to overcome Donald Trump's gravitas
his imposing figure his quick wit
that primary is going to make both of
them very very good and whoever can't
win it doesn't deserve to win it if
Trump goes in there and just crushes
DeSantis and policy becomes completely
irrelevant then it deserves to if you
can't convince people to vote on the
merits then you don't deserve to be the
nominee so but if DeSantis comes in and
says Bing Bang Boom here's what I've
done and it resonates with people and
Trump is unable to counter that then
Trump doesn't deserve to take it what
about Kerry Lake you guys think she's
going to run for president no because
she just she Heidi Hobbs was overseeing
the election in Arizona won the election
uh so now Kerry Lake lost the election
yeah but she's not in office she's not
in politics she's famous though and
she's well liked I don't think it would
be good if she ran just not good for
them people are going to be snowing yeah
people are going to say if she can't win
a state election what makes her what
makes her think that she could trouble
Trump wasn't a politician before he won
yeah but but Trump's Trump was massively
famous though it's true it's true but
but you know I guess we can see I just
don't like the idea of these people who
lose elections just trying to up their
elections like Beto yeah
that sounds very familiar to me I I
think if Kerry Lake if uh she should
fight 110 I believe that everybody
should be protesting peacefully in
Arizona there's 1.3 1.2 million people
voted for all 1.2 million should be out
in the streets especially in Maricopa
just because the the the busted up
voting machines disenfranchised people
and you don't even know who left the
lines who went home because of because
of the failure of the voting process and
that benefits Democrats so I will stress
this the difference between fraud and
impropriety the different so fraud is
initially the narrative was voting
machines stealing votes
um people forging ballots and things
like that now it seems like people
people are saying the fraud narrative is
ballot harvesting and um voting machines
breaking and I'm like okay well that's a
different conversation if the voting
machines are just garbage and can't
adequately handle the the amount of
people that are coming in to vote then
Democrats are winning because they do
the early mail-in votes if the issue is
ballot harvesting and it's legal in
these states then Democrats are winning
because they have found a way to just
get the numbers and it's a horrifying
Prospect it doesn't matter anymore to
win the hearts and minds of the people
it matters to convince someone who's not
paying attention to sign their name to a
piece of paper and then you leave and
they don't even know what it was about I
was looking at that's scary Katie Hobbs
uh Wikipedia page and one of the last
sentences in the 2022 gubernatorial
election section is that Hobbes decided
not to debate the Republic looking
nominee Kerry Lake to deny Lake a
platform to spread election denialism
you deny a candidate a chance to speak
is that not a form of election denialism
it's not the same thing it's not the
same thing but what a weird sentence
yeah she denied Carrie an opportunity
because she was going to deny something
let me let me tell you real quick what
was what was Katie hobb's role in the in
the Arizona election exactly because
I've heard she's in charge of it I just
want to be clear what was her role
Secretary of State she was the Secretary
of State of her own
elections herself yes so was Brian
Campbell I just got to make an excuse
either a deal it doesn't Excuse excuse
either of them but I'm seeing so many
people come out and being like I can't
believe something like this would happen
and it's like yeah and Brian Kemp did
the same but how is it legal and we said
it shouldn't have happened then and it
shouldn't be happening now but uh the
system is just as just ridiculous stupid
broken system so so it's it's annoyingly
frustrating and no you're right maybe it
should not be allowed it shouldn't have
been allowed back then it shouldn't be
allowed now I'm going to leave it to the
global superpower to screw up the fact
that you should ride on a piece of paper
and put it in a box and then count how
many pieces of paper in that box have
the same thing written on it right I
mean we've we've thrown in we've decided
to computerize our our elections we've
made them all electronic completely
ignoring the fact that you have all the
technical experts Who come out and say
anything you know all of these machines
are susceptible right and and so here we
are we've over complicated A system that
you know we could trace back to uh you
know athene Athens Greece centuries ago
you know 2 000 years ago plus three
thousand years you know we're looking at
the Athenians perfected this sort of
system where they would even write on a
Shard of pottery right but here we are
we've over complicated it in allegedly
in the world's only less superpower
Still Standing uh where this is supposed
to be the The Benchmark of of uh
civilization right Democratic
civilization we figured out a way to
screw it up up or at least the
bureaucrats here's what I want to see I
want to see Donald Trump come out
tonight and say
gas prices are too high
we need energy Independence and energy
Independence our border is porous and
worse than it's ever been
I want him to come out and say we need
to bring jobs back we need to bring
factories back we need to stop this
military expansion the war in Ukraine is
not America's business
I am that's what I want I want to hear
Maga I want to hear Donald Trump talk
about how he wants to make this country
great I want to hear him tell a story
about a nice family sitting out in their
backyard in a rocking chair dad's
reading the paper moms coming out with
some fresh sun tea kids are playing and
he's talking about how the working class
is going to have a better chance at
succeeding in this country
if it is an issue with the ballot
harvesting all that stuff that's a
matter for their strategy to win but not
to win the hearts and minds of the
people to win the election I get I just
kind of feel like if they come out and
they don't talk about issues they're
offering up nothing of substance you
know what I mean look you're talking
you're talking salesmanship instead you
know salesmanship versus statesmanship
right yeah and and you know let's be
honest he could get up there and he
could paint the prettiest of pictures
about what he would intend to do right
the whole
Maga thing right make America great
again but let's be honest at what the
situation is the federal government is
terminally broken right four years
where he was going to drain the swamp
the swamp is deeper than it's ever been
right our lives are still controlled
under 180 000 pages of federal laws
rules and regulations administered by
440 separate agencies and two and a half
million unelected Federal bureaucrats
right the federal debt has gone up to
the point now that our children's
Children's children's children are still
going to be paying on it right so
nothing got done our tax money is being
taken paid to overpaid civil servants
most of them make more than the governor
of our state right where that money in
turn is funneled back into Democratic
coffers that are out there now openly
pushing neo-marx's Theory and philosophy
as public policy the the so he can
promise whatever he wants to promise but
at the end of the day the federal system
anything connected to it is going to be
tainted just like it is and we're we
might as well be Tethered to the Titanic
headed to the bottom of the North
Atlantic I'm curious if he's going to
announce you know two thousand dollar
checks for everyone just like he did 10
grand last time
in all seriousness I would accept if
Donald Trump comes out and says I am
going to be running on one platform
everyone gets fifteen thousand dollars
cash oh so he joined the Yang gang well
Joe Biden came out and offered 10 grand
to everybody in their pocket
unconstitutionally and they they vote
for it oh no so there you go if the
system is going to crumble and fall then
Trump may as well just come out and be
like sure I'll play 15 20 30. one word
from Trump graphene we're gonna build
the greatest graphene production
facility on Earth the best we are the
best all his friends confused I've been
obsessively telling his friends when
they come here to be on our show tell
Donald Trump graphing this is it this is
the future we become a graphene
industrialist Nation do it Donald this
is your chance and this is it baby they
leave thinking like that's cool that
guy's kind of weird yeah you gotta be a
little more specific we also have to
remember when Donald Trump was was
running uh in 2016 he was promising a
lot of things he was talking about
ending the Federal Reserve he was he was
hinting at 9 11 conspiracies he was
hitting uh you know out of the park when
it came to going at the media one-on-one
is he going to be that same Donald Trump
from 2002 16 we're going to see but I
think a lot of people want Solutions not
complaining and if he's going to be
complaining he's going to lose a lot of
his base as a lot of people are already
saying hey there's there's no reason I
should be supporting this because this
is not going to help anyone he's just
going to indebt us and Rob us of our
money let's talk about uh the other
possibility I guess and that's a
peaceful divorce peaceful divorce I like
that you mentioned uh Donald Trump you
know it would be good if he came out
announced he was going to put on the
ballot secession for every state or
something of that effect yeah look you
know here's here's the thing that I
think everyone needs to kind of
understand is that this idea of
Independence or shuffling of of the
political structure has been in the wind
for a long time look I personally been
working on the Texas Independence issue
since August 24th 1996 right so I've
been at this a long time but what's
amazing is since this undercurrent has
been happening it's not just Texas right
Alaska has had an independence party
since the 80s the whole Joe Vogler story
is pretty pretty impressive it should be
a movie but there's you know emerging
Independence movements in in California
in New Hampshire and Vermont a lot of
other states I mean we're hearing talk
of flex it now uh but the the bottom
line here is simply this the the
movement toward the shuffling of the
political structure and outright
Independence is not new and it's not
rare and it's not unpopular yeah I'm
sharing a statistic with the guys
earlier that most people don't realize
there was a poll a survey USA poll that
dropped in the summer that showed that
support for Texas was at 66 percent of
likely voters in Texas wow and that's
not an aberration right so you roll it
back to 2009 the research 2000 poll it
was about 30 some odd percent I like to
joke that when we founded the tnm in
2005 it was polling in singles that's
our organization the Texas Nationals
movement but you know we've always
polled higher than the approval rating
of the United States Congress which
polls somewhere right a below above or
below leprosy right I mean they're not
particularly popular you'll get that
later the leprosy thing right but anyway
you know the whole thing is that this
has been a steady progression of support
a lot of it driven by a bunch of on the
ground work that we've done since 2005
but obviously a lot of it driven by the
deteriorating situation with the federal
government where more and more people
feel disconnected so the 66 percent was
not an aberration you know there was a
there was a pull down of five different
regions in the U.S they asked them
whether they supported their region
seceding from the union yeah and I
normalized so you have five different
region pollings Democrat Republican
independent I normalized for for state
population and and you know the numbers
and uh when you when you normalize 37.2
percent of people in the United States
want their region to secede some more so
than others right uh in the Midwest
Independence the plurality wants
secession in the South it's the majority
with uh it's Republicans wanting
secession in California in the west
coast it's Democrats that want secession
so well look I mean that's the the
polling on this issue the mainstream
media anytime they decide to dig off
into the polling on this issue they do
something weird like that where let's
look at it by region instead of by state
right which is not the way that it works
it doesn't work by our region every
state as a political entity would have
the ability to put it on the ballot and
withdraw right so 2014 during the time
of the Scottish independence referendum
wrote that Reuters episode poll did
exactly the same thing and so they
lumped Texas in with the Southwest which
was New Mexico and Arizona and obviously
New Mexico is not a state that's going
to want to break away so they did that
to skew the numbers but we got a hold of
the crosstabs In The Raw data and did
the same thing that's when that was the
first time we discovered that texit was
polling at 54 percent Republican half of
independent voters and 35 percent of
Democrats right that was the bombshell
but instead it was 35 percent of people
in the South southwest region want their
state to leave right it's garbage so
what do you do with that number
well uh pretty much what we do right so
there is a there is a process right
there is a process and um what I what I
tell people is look if you look overseas
right you you we've got plenty of
examples of Independence referenda
around the world uh and that's
ultimately where this is headed is to a
vote when people think of Texas they
need to think about what they saw in
Scotland in 2014 brexit a couple years
later we're going to put it on the
ballot and last uh actually last
legislative session in Texas we had the
Texas Independence referendum act
introduced by state representative Kyle
biederman that would have done just that
it would have allowed the voters to go
to the polls and look down at a ballot
and answer the question should the state
of Texas reassert its status as an
independent nation that ultimately is is
what people need to to do is they need
to be given the choice a good bit of the
reason that we've been able to build
support is because of how how we've been
talking about this issue to the people
this is what we ask them imagine right
now if if Texas or your state was
already a self-governing Nation right
you had control over your own border and
immigration policy your own military
your own currency and monetary policy
you know you you had your own uh
military you had your own passports your
own embassies you had your own Olympic
team you had everything that 200 other
self-governing independent nations
around the world has okay fix that in
your mind and then ask yourself this
instead of talking about withdrawing
from the union imagine if you were
talking about whether or not your state
your self-governing independent nation
state should join the union knowing
everything you know about the federal
government right now would you vote to
join
hell no well it depends on him
welcome you to the team if we were being
invaded by like cartels like literally
like a 10 000 man cartel army with maybe
they had bomb if they're dropping bombs
on cities like we'd have no choice but
to petition the United States to join
the union at that point for defense well
okay let's just let's just be clear that
any state that would be a self-governing
independent nation already would already
have control of its National Defense you
know down here let's let's be honest
you're talking about the cartels and
people ask that question about Texas all
the time we've got Boy Scout Troops that
are more well-armed than the cartels
okay in Texas I mean that's a bit of an
exaggeration but I think you get the
point the these issues that people bring
up about you know that sort of Safety
and Security understand that 200 other
countries around the world have already
figured this out right they already
defend them defend themselves from
Attack as a matter of fact in in the
particular instance as I talked about
the Border earlier part of the biggest
challenge that we have in Texas is the
fact that our border is Left unchecked
Right Where when you have sheriffs in
Texas saying that the federal government
has neglected securing the border to
such a point that the cartels are
effectively in control of the Rio Grande
River guess what uh we're already under
attack and the federal government is
doing nothing about it is it preventing
Texas from defending itself
well I think Texas could take that step
I mean you know we I've been very
critical of grow of Governor Greg Abbott
I know uh Chad was on the show not too
long ago and Chad and I've talked about
this quite a bit it's been a pretty
constant refrain as we want the governor
to call an invasion to declare an
invasion which he allegedly did today
right but he said that he was invoking
that Invasion Clause under article 4
section 4 of the U.S Constitution but he
gave a laundry list of things that Texas
was in fact already doing right you know
uh escorting illegal immigrants back to
the border which is effectively Catch
and Release right because they go
immediately back into Federal custody
who then runs them through the pipeline
and ships them all over the United
States gives them Asylum all those sorts
of things you know increase the gun
boats down on the Rio Grande river we
already have those right so he gave a
big one why doesn't he arrest the people
who are traveling him well that includes
that includes purported uh people
masquerading as law enforcement well
they they do that I mean to a certain
extent but not to the number so you have
to go back to when you hear Greg Abbott
talking about operation Lone Star uh we
kind of refer to it as operation half
measure right because operation Lone
Star started back when I think Perry uh
Governor Perry
uh started working on that issue uh and
he decided Well I'm going to increase
Department of Public Safety patrols 35
you know up to 30 miles in from the
border right so it wasn't Border
Protection it was we're going to run
traffic patrols to see if maybe we can
possibly catch some of these Smugglers
right and so Abbott's program has
effectively been to expand on that
program but it's a very it's not very
different at all uh you'll you'll hear
him say that he's put National Guard
down on the border and in fact he has
but so if they if if they uh catch some
illegal immigrants and then bring them
to the border and then a couple of guys
show up claiming they're with the
federal government and bring them back
in what does Texas do
say oh okay all right well so they get
turned over into Federal custody who's
they the the illegal immigrants so when
they are interdicted by the state they
get uh they get taken back to the border
which immediately puts them back into
Federal custody the federal government
will put them in detention centers or in
some cases put them up in hotels that
they rent with taxpayer money then those
illegal immigrants are processed out of
that facility handed over effectively to
ngos who take taxpayer money give them
funds and then uh ship them around
around the country so generally you'll
see that pipeline happen where they are
transferred from those detention
facilities to the airports in in Houston
or San Antonio they are lined up they're
given they're given cash payments in
most instances of your tax money
funneled through these ngos like
Catholic Charities they're giving it in
an envelope the coyotes come out of line
they take their cut they get on the on
the plane and get flown out to God only
knows where right and then the coyote
pops out of line and goes back and runs
the whole gamut again and so the federal
government when we talk when we're
critical about the federal government On
the Border this is not just neglect
right this is intentional what's
happening down there on the border they
are facilitating this and our criticism
for governor Abbott has been he has not
taken strong enough measures look our
our organization has advocated for for
years and years and years what needs to
happen is rather than calling up the
National Guard Texas has a three branch
military called the Texas Military
Department two branches of International
Guard but one estate guard we've we've
advocated that Greg Abbott and and the
legislature should effectively shift
funds from the National Guard units in
the Texas Military Department fully fund
fully militarize the Texas state guard
and then declare an invasion and have
Governor Abbott as the
commander-in-chief of the Texas military
forces deploy them down to support a
protection force and if the federal
government didn't like it they could go
pound sand and the big fear is on their
part is that it will cause a
constitutional crisis well so what I
don't care about a constitutional crisis
I have a border crisis and an invasion
that's happening that any Sovereign
self-governing independent nation could
take care of but we're not allowed to
but that is one of the reasons that
people are clamoring to have taxes
because self-governing independent
nations get to take care of them let me
let me pull this story from timcast.com
that should really grind your gears New
York City to house migrants in four-star
hotel where rooms cost hundreds per
night
how come I don't get a four-star hotel
what do you know my taxpayer dollars
paying for these these people this is
the crazy thing about what's been going
on that we've got this this massive
breach of the Southern border seems only
to be getting worse and then even when
these people come in and are shipped
around the country these cities are
propping them up putting them up and
giving them the gold star treatment
meanwhile you've got Americans suffering
under the opioid crisis you've got
unemployment skyrocketing inflation but
it's the non-citizens who are being
given all the Privileges and the
benefits this is why a lot of people
like you know aside from Texas people
are saying peaceful divorce or whatever
you want to call it yeah I mean you know
the the term that flies around a lot is
National divorce and you know the you
see all these maps of people with
different counties and you know the red
should but but that's that's not how
this works right the good news is we got
about 75 or 80 years of kind of world
history to look at to see how this thing
goes down and in the the thing that I
think should motivate people is to
understand that this sort of divorce
force that we're talking about States
withdrawing from the Union
relieves a tremendous amount of the
pressure right I mean how many articles
have you seen recently where people are
saying there's another civil war coming
right has it already started but
understand that when you allow states to
stand up and be self-governing
independent nations they have the
ability to say like California governor
California let Texas govern Texas let
New York Governor New York and we can do
like every other self-governing
independent nation around the world we
can trade with one another we can travel
between one another we can agree to
defend one another when we have common
National Defense concerns we can do the
things that that honestly the founders
and framers probably envisioned for a
union of the states much better than
having to take a knee to two and a half
million unelected bureaucrats in
Washington DC Texas was also an
independent country for about 10 years
after five years I think was it five we
got we got a solid nine in nine years
nine years nine years they were they
were their own country
um and again what New York City is doing
is taking tax dollars probably also from
the federal government and putting
people in hotels right outside homeless
drug dens where the average citizen
there is of course affected by the
opioid epidemic that of course was
engineered by big Pharma in The
Regulators uh Tim I'm also seeing what
you're seeing I don't know if you want
to talk about it specifically uh what
what is happening to uh Rumble yeah
rumble's crashing
um but I also wanted to let you know
that the guardian on YouTube is having a
live stream of Trump's announcements as
well the guardian on YouTube the
guardian on YouTube so I think also if
we play their stream if we get in
trouble and they don't it shows a lot of
hypocrisy that they're able to show the
live stream and we're not able to show
where where I'm on the Guardians
so hold on I'm gonna find out right now
um the the exact title and the exact
channel it's guardian and news it's the
Channel with 2.9 Million uh followers
and it's called expected to announce
yeah so that's live right now and look
at that that safeguards us a little bit
as Rumble is down
the concern here is that Trump's going
to say things and YouTube's gonna
YouTube uh did this I think they did to
Crystal and Sagar uh over at breaking
points they've done it to rsbn they've
done it to Major I think even like ABC
got hit once
um you know I think maybe Fox because
you report on what Trump says they shut
you down and it's the craziest thing
well YouTube popped us we did so last
session we filed the Texas Independence
referendum act they did the committee
didn't give it a hearing which state
affairs didn't give a hearing so we did
what was effectively a virtual hearing
we had uh we had voters submit videos in
the style of of testimony and we ran it
and the whole thing was like 24 hours
worth of testimony and and we streamed
portions of it on YouTube as as we did
it and sure enough man we got popped
with a community strike or one of those
violations
um for for Testimony like literally
testimony of Voters and there was none
of that you know it wasn't people can
you know talking about
I will stress this though uh I will file
a lawsuit in 30 minutes if YouTube does
that to us because they have we have a
contractual agreement and this is where
Alex Berenson actually uh won with
Twitter there's a contractual agreement
that every user has with the platform
they use especially for a show like ours
that is a that is a financial contract
contract that we produce content revenue
is sold by YouTube the revenue is split
if they breach that contract by
suspending our access without us doing
anything wrong then I'm gonna hold them
personally responsible for the Lost
revenue and then demand an immediate
reinstatement and uh and and at the very
least you know the strike lasts about a
week but I'll pursue it you know all the
way to the end to get that money back
the point is this no one here
is claiming there's fraud no one on this
show if Donald Trump makes some some
statement that violates their rules it
is not us as doing a show and offering
commentary they can play those games all
they want but uh uh you know also in two
seconds doesn't mean we'll win but go
get them tiger well that's what we saw
Alex Berenson got got suspended from
Twitter yeah and uh they successfully
sued saying that the Twitter made an
agreement that he would be given notice
of anything he did wrong and they didn't
they just removed him and they removed
him because the White House was
pressuring Twitter to do so so he got
reinstated there's also a very
compelling case showing hey the guardian
and the corporate media gets to do this
why can't we do this if it's really a
violation of their rules and regulations
why are they allowed to do it and we
aren't and this has been happening
throughout so many years on YouTube
specifically uh allowing the corporate
media to play by a different set of
rules while of course hurting people
that do exactly what they do showing the
same footage showing the same kind of
accounts making the same kind of
arguments showing the same debates but
if you don't have the connections with
of course the establishment with if
you're not the corporate media if you're
not the approved press you get punished
and dinged by it how can a judge see
something like that and say yeah this is
accurate this is totally okay for a
multinational corporation to do on the
world stage when it comes to a major
information Highway when it comes to the
public interest the public good it's
absolutely inexcusable what YouTube has
been doing recently and it deserves to
be pushed back on I think it also is
important if someone on your show starts
spouting off and saying things that are
violate the sites terms of service that
you push back and explain that that's
violating terms of service and you can
but is the guardian going to do that is
the guardian if Trump says something is
the guardian going to stop the stream
and say Trump is wrong are they going to
do that we will do that and it's
important that we do because people need
to know what the terms of service are
firstly and why things are happening the
way they're happening where do you have
where do you have reporting and where do
you have commentary
I don't know what this is all about what
this is not private the guardian went
made up they're watching the show
they're like oh they're on to us it's no
longer a secret yeah it's gone Guardian
guardian just shut down the rumbles back
up from what I'm seeing but why did the
guardian shut down their stream maybe
they were like oh we're gonna get banned
yeah I'll just I'll say this like
what what YouTube has done with the
censorship rules has um created this
ridiculous media system that
if we host an interview with someone and
that individual says bad things we are
held responsible for it like so what
don't interview anybody ever again right
right how are you are we going to
challenge bad ideas how can we put
really bad ideas in check we can't and
and when you have so much censorship you
not only destroy the narrative but you
essentially try to of course have some
kind of psychotic mind control by not
even explaining the rules clearly the
the terms and services are very vague
they're very generalized and many times
people get punished and they're they're
not even told these vague generalized
rules and they have to self-censor
themselves which destroys the discourse
and destroys human progression human
progression is unparalleled with free
speech the more you deny Free Speech the
less humans prosper
and it's and it's ridiculous you know
speaking of challenging bad ideas I want
to talk about secession I'm just kidding
that was a joke by the way but that was
not I do want to talk about it because
that's your dead pan delivery through me
did you like it I'm actually very
concerned about it because it's what
kicked off the Civil War the first
American Civil War was a secession
movement that'd be great that it'll
prevent one this time well what what I'm
concerned about is a situation where
Texas like we're out we voted we're done
and the federal government's like nah
that's our oil we send it around the
country that's our golf that's our golf
uh our Gulf of Mexico access we want it
and we need that Mexican trade route so
we're taking it back you can't walk with
our property and then there's just comes
to blows other states are like hey
federal government you can't just go in
on a state like that they're Sovereign
then they join the secessionist movement
something like that again and how would
you avoid something like that well I
think I think what we're doing is is
trying to avoid that I mean that's why
we're following a process and this is
what I tell people you know the good
news is is that when we woke up today uh
it wasn't the 1800s right so post-civil
War the the world kept spinning things
started happening in the position on
this has evolved quite a bit right so
you look at what the federal government
has done literally since 1945 I'd say
you know post post World War II they've
sent our grandfathers grandmothers
fathers mothers some of the people
probably watching today our sons and
daughters I conclude my son uh off to
fight protect bleed some instances die
for the right of self-determination for
other people so you know what we're
talking about here in this process is
effectively the process that we have
seen the United States protect around
the world which is you put a question of
this importance to the people you let
them debate the issue and then you let
them vote on it and then you respect the
outcome of the vote now that being said
you know could the federal government be
at react poorly sure they could but you
know what does that say then ultimately
about the federal government right what
does it say because at the moment they
begin to start acting like bash or
al-assad or North Korea or you know any
of these other folks I mean they pretty
well just told us exactly why what we're
doing they've legitimized our position
in why the people of Texas voted that
way anyway do you think that Abe Lincoln
reacted poorly when he started a war to
stop the secession do I think he reacted
poorly yeah I believe Abe Lincoln
probably uh reacted poorly I think that
probably could have been him but here's
the thing I'm not here to adjudicate the
past right I'm not here to to try to
look back and second guess what happened
in the 1800s I'm here to try to look
forward to see what Texas can do to
prevent what's happening to it right now
we're we're about to you know 14 or 15
minutes away from Trump being an
announcement but we're talking about
censorship so I want to pull up this
story from the post-millennial breaking
Elon Musk welcomes ligma and Johnson
back to Twitter so these are these are
two employee a former employees who
they're getting their jobs back
congratulations to ligma and Johnson for
uh getting your jobs act no I'm just
kidding these guys they hoaxed the media
walked out of Twitter HQ carrying boxes
and then claimed that they had been
fired the post millennial now reports in
an unexpected heartwarming move Elon
Musk welcomed back quote former
employees ligma and Johnson to Twitter
headquarters today
Rahul ligma and Daniel Johnson are
fictitious names used by two pranksters
who were able to dupe mainstream media
into believing that they were woke
Twitter employees who had just been
fired not everybody was uh it wasn't
just the mainstream media that fell for
it I of course did a report on it
um mentioning they thought that it was a
hoax so uh turns out it was but the
reason I bring this story up while we're
dealing with the insane rules of YouTube
and the the ridiculous policies that are
that are it's impossible to adhere to
I've forgotten so for a long period I
was getting I wasn't getting demonetized
anymore
as soon as we get to election season all
the videos are demonetized and it's very
very obvious here's what happens
YouTube my understanding is they use
third-party monetization Checkers or
whatever
they said that my politics talk talking
about like the polls are here and here
was dangerous or gratuitous violence
demonetized okay I then have to contact
my rep at Google and say hey they're
doing it again and they go oh sorry
about that we'll fix it my response is
no no not sorry about it we'll fix it at
a certain point when you you have an
observable pattern of Twitter's I'm
sorry of YouTube's contractors lying to
strip ads off the content you have got a
breach of contract and I shouldn't have
to then go to someone at Google and be
like oh by the way your guys are lying
again yeah now all my videos
automatically demonetized 24 hours after
the videos get all of their hits then
they get remonetized which of course
leaves me with barely any money my
income on YouTube by the way it went
down one-fourth of what it used to be in
these key particular times as my
viewership has skyrocketed more than it
ever has before but my income is is at
its lowest that it has on on YouTube
what's going on there I mean obviously
playing a dirty game it's just
ridiculous Instagram right now
reinstated a warning whenever you sign
up to my account out whenever you try to
follow me on Instagram at lukewe or
change or not it will tell you do you
sure you want to follow this guy he
spreads a lot of fake news what kind of
fake news am I starting I'm spreading
memes and and and uh one of our guests
just tweeted the photo of this warning
telling people not to sign there right I
can't even search for you yeah Luke we
are change yeah on Instagram and it
wouldn't surprise me if they banned me
to the point where you can't even find
me uh but there's a photo that I just
tweeted on Twitter showing specifically
do not follow this guy he's he's
spreading this information I spread
memes that's that's all I do memes that
you could interpret in many different
you should you should you should sue for
defamation yeah absolutely absolutely
because it's it's this account has
repeatedly posted false information that
was reviewed by independent fact
Checkers or went against our community
guidelines I think you should file a
lawsuit let's do it if there's a lawyer
let's do this right now uh hit me up
let's let's set up
let's do it right now Luke we are and
you're you don't come up and I'm
following you already
James Lawrence we had him on the show
hit him up and uh send a demand letter
that they they've defamed you they've
accused you of something yeah that that
is that is untrue and absolutely untrue
because the thing is they got me on are
are ridiculous they got me because I
showed a picture of all the Jets from uh
at the at the at the world economic
Forum meeting it was a legit photo and
they said no no it's a fake photo
because some people are sharing that
with another photo that's fake and I'm
like what that that makes no sense at
all the fact jerkers have been wrong
time and time again they are there to
stifle any kind of legitimate
conversations they're there to attack
comedy they're there to go after humor
I'm here just to make people laugh you
can interpret memes and pictures in so
many different ways and for them to
objectively say you are bad because you
made people lie income and my bottom
line is of course if when people can't
find me when people are told not to
follow me this is the predominant way of
of me making my income this is how I
make my livelihood and you know
let's show a big middle finger to
Instagram go on at Luke we are change
and and let's let's fight the algorithms
let's fight all this censorship and all
this bull crap because it's more
important than ever that our voices are
heard because they're trying to silence
us for a very specific here's the
important thing I'll add when you get
they say you know posted false
information or whatever by fact Checkers
that's actually not what a lot of it is
some of it's missing context which is
not false information and if that's the
case if Instagram has flagged your
account Luke saying you've posted false
information that's been reviewed by fact
Checkers you should go through your
posts because I I know for a fact some
of them were just like this post is
missing context in which case
Facebook or meta's automatic system
assumes if you get flagged it was for
posting false information that's a huge
error they issued a statement outside of
what the fact Checkers actually said I
think you would you you would win that
you said a demand letter and you'd win
in two seconds absolutely let's begin
the process right now because it's just
getting ridiculous I've been dealing
with this stuff for for over 12 years
now and it's only getting worse and
worse and worse and and this is well but
this is why I brought up Elon Musk
because actually I think it's starting
to get better Elon Musk is going on
Twitter and just laughing at the woke
employees that he's firing and he's
ragging on Democrats he's saying the
Democrats won't be investigated for
financial crimes it's just I mean this
is pretty good news you know uh there's
some questions about whether or not Elon
Musk can pull this off and and Twitter
might actually go to business we'll see
but hey I'll take it right yeah I mean
and this is why I've been so optimistic
about Twitter again we should be a
little bit critical of Elon Musk but at
the same time he's promising something
that could change the game that could
make the world a better place just by
allowing people to talk to each other
just by allowing comedy on the platform
and this is why this whole ligma Johnson
thing brilliant smart it's making people
laugh it's silly it's ridiculous it's
upon on on on on on something that
people should be making their jokes
about there's something interesting too
because I retweeted this um we have Noah
Sanders just super chatted that uh
quartering reported Elon is offering 10
over YouTube to larger channels uh I've
not heard that directly but I know know
he's tweeted someone said someone
tweeted that if Elon offered 10 percent
more than YouTube paid to content
creators those creators would move to
Twitter yes that is a fact Elon if you
made a video page for my Twitter profile
I would upload my content there and uh
and if you if you monetized it
when I post videos on Twitter I often
get more views than I do on YouTube but
there's just kind of no point for one my
videos are longer and you don't really
get anything for doing it if Elon Musk
does create a video monetization
function then then it's there people are
saying that there was a live skip during
my rant about censorship as well on the
platform but I don't know I got I gotta
I gotta you know fact check that as well
but if Elon Muslim if Elon Musk even
does less than than 20 of what YouTube's
doing I'm jumping because it's an
alternative platform that that is
promising to follow basic guidelines and
to just allow speech that is free that
is legal and and that is worth any
amount of money that that is worth all
the money in the world right now because
if I'm able to just say whatever I want
if I'm not having to self-censor myself
if I'm not having to walk this tight
line if I'm able to be my true authentic
self and just speak freely from the top
of my mind that's that's a gift give me
less income give me half of what
YouTube's giving me I'll be on your
platform immediately right now well look
they're the same people the same people
that are doing this to speech are the
same people they do it in economics as
well that love to put their thumb on the
scale and pick winners and losers right
and so you know ultimately what we're
saying is let the marketplace of ideas
Prevail exactly if an idea if an idea
sucks the people will let you know
sooner rather than later yeah stop
curating and treating us like small
children stop telling us what we should
be looking at stop trying to shove
corporate propaganda down our throat we
don't want to watch your bull crap we
don't want to watch the woke movies the
nonsense and all this nonsensical idiocy
we don't want any of that we want
legitimate real honest conversations and
that's something that we are being
denied of we're being denied the access
to laugh at things in order to not make
them as serious as they are we're being
denied the ability to find out what's
really happening in this world so we can
make the right decision to not be heard
over and screwed over by the most
powerful people in this world and we're
beginning screwed over more and more by
these powerful special interests by big
Pharma and all these other criminals out
there that profit off of your ignorance
Society is becoming dumber and more and
and more stupid mainly because of this
censorship and it needs to end and it
needs to end now rumble's crashing yeah
too many people want to be there or not
or it could be a deliberate attack could
be that too if that's because because
now because now it's like okay YouTube's
not going to allow this Rumble list
let's all go to rumble and watch this
speech as of course YouTube is going to
be most likely censoring this is why the
guardian maybe just stopped they got it
now we got the uh
we got the live feed
is that Jared Kushner about five minutes
out it looks like Kushner
about five minutes out I could tell uh
because we just dropped 10 000
concurrent viewers everyone's jumping to
go watch hey keep watching our show you
guys well you know watch both at the
same time and I do whatever you want we
don't lower the volume because it's cool
YouTube used to have that hardcore say
anything you want not anything obviously
we're within the bounds of law always
but just this this wild west is like
2006 you would say anything to anybody
and they would say it back and you would
have the most deep intense painful
enlightening conversations with people
about the about real world issues about
people's feelings and it created
Community it created like a sense of
strength Google was so into it that they
bought the company like YouTube this is
before Google owned them and then I I
then I one of my friends got banned
Warren 25 was his screen name and it was
like the first Banning on YouTube and I
was erratic about it either this video
Warren 25 smash band or something where
I'm losing my mind about it
um and I was concerned since once you
start getting corporate conglomeration
and that that the the history has shown
that the company will try and take
control once you start punishing people
for an expression for expressing an
opinion you're the bad guy you're the
Baddie okay that it's a it's a sure it's
as simple as that throughout human
history the people who censor other
individuals they're not the good guys
they're the bad guys
it looks like the guard the guardian
take it down again
maybe it's not them there we go there we
go that's so weird what's going on with
this
well you know I mean piggyback off of
what you were saying I mean the the
thing we have to remember
uh and and there is a certain course of
people out there that that say that say
look we've got you know these guys are
private companies they could do whatever
you know they're not private but they're
not the moment they took dollar one of
taxpayer money right they became a they
became a public forum not just that the
DHS is literally telling them you're
gonna ban this person this person this
person they're not going to be allowed
to have a voice they're making fun of
fauci here that's a parody account
that's not allowed here we can't be
making fun of our politicians we need to
have control of the narrative because
when we do we have control of the people
quite literally they're not a private
company anymore when they go public
they're now a public company maybe we
should have different laws and
regulations for public social networks
there's also there's also in queue tell
the whole thing from the very beginning
stinks hey hey people a lot of people
are saying Luke they jumped you and uh
our viewership jumped back up When we
dropped viewers I was I was seeing
viewers drop and I was like oh it must
be because people are jumping over not
because no no
it went back up which typically means
for those people the stream stopped
working everyone's saying mid-rant I was
cut off I bet there's a lot of global
Madness that right now because Trump's
about to say something remember when
you're talking about the CIA you got cut
off as well yep and then we stopped
talking about the CIA and then we got
back on and then we started talking
about the CIA again and they started
coming and remember it was like I was
like there's like a feds who are
watching the show and they have their
finger on the throttle button maybe
they're like eating Donuts remember when
I was talking about God and then you
lost control of the machine like a
couple weeks ago you're like I can't
control this thing what's going on like
what do you mean it was like two or
three weeks ago I was like really
intensely feeling like emotions about
God or something and you're like I can't
control this machine I was like get
ready for it it's gonna happen more oh
like the monitors flicker like some
weird thing happened and then all of a
sudden I was like what's going on it's
official according to the the uh the
Federal Election Commission Trump has
officially announced that he's going to
be running for 2024
he has officially filed the paperwork to
be president do you have that on Twitter
I just uh I'm I'm uh I'm tweeting it
right now I got a text from uh from
someone saying Luke's rant got clipped
I guess you'll have to do it again uh
isn't it funny though it's just like at
least we can laugh about it yeah well my
YouTube channel is a we are changed that
that's been getting hit uh all the time
uh from the very beginning so uh again I
think it's OG OG demonetized Luke was
the first demonetized channel so I think
it's more important than ever to to make
sure you people follow people on their
original platforms I had a members area
for about 10 years I know you have your
members area uh mine's just Luke
unsensor.com but it's more important
than ever to go on Independent websites
support your independent content creator
because if you guys don't do it there's
no other way for us to to make a living
out here especially for me myself with
with YouTube automatically demonetizing
everything and then monetizing it when
no one's watching the videos again it's
absolutely
I think if you Google
you can pull up the FEC filing
maybe maybe not maybe not so I just
tweeted it right now
um Luke at Luke we are changing when you
were saying your stuff was getting
demonetized then a day later it would be
were you actually like contacting us now
I have no one to contact there's no one
to contact at YouTube for the majority
of creators every time I release a video
automatically demonetized and then you
click you know review 24 hours or more
green it's good to go but then no one's
watching the videos right the most of
the money is made in the first 24 hours
most of most of the views are in the
first 24 hours so so that's how they get
you that's how they get they hit you
again so signing up to timcast.com
signing up to Luke uncensor.com it this
is the way that we need to do this
because there's no other way of of
supporting content creators because the
old models are gone also uh Daniel
what's your website oh we got it that's
right yeah I got the I got the link Luke
posted the image I'm gonna post the link
along with it of Donald Trump's official
I'm tweeting this out
uh Donald Trump's official FEC filing is
now available Link at on Twitter at
timcast and uh
there it is oh it's a similar here we go
here we go here we go it's happening
it's coming
[Music]
everyone's got their phones now they're
singing Les Mis
[Music]
[Applause]
great Musical
but it's about the French Revolution
where's the escalator Gentlemen please
welcome the next president and first
lady there we go that was the spoiler
president Donald J Trump accompanied by
Mrs Melania Trump
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look how weird it is that all the phones
the images on the phones don't line up
with what's in front of them
there should be a grand entrance there
there should be more Showmanship here
so he file I tweeted it out you can
there it is yeah he's officially
announced I mean you don't know he could
be skydiving into the Skylight I mean we
don't know it could be a body double
yeah I'm hoping don't assume his
entrance
gonna be burst out of somebody's stomach
you know you never know alien Style
okay well skydiving's office too this
song is so cheap I mean it was probably
public but it is old I like the song I
think it's a great song If there's one
song You're gonna come out to
this is really weird because that's the
French Revolution stuff there he is he's
looking good huh
[Music]
actually yeah he did look look like
getting younger
[Music]
the first thing he's gonna say is like
they stole it from me
no no let's hear it I'm excited for this
guys it's gonna be this is gonna be an
awesome next couple of years I'm really
excited for this
gonna let the whole song play
[Music]
we don't need to hear the music
no more Lee Greenwood's over there going
dollar dollar bills y'all where's the
fireworks come on Trump start talking
[Music]
it's one thing to be proud of what
you've done if you're just proud that
you were born here it's kind of like
gloating
I disagree I don't know we're the
luckiest people on the face of this
Earth lucky but why would we go here we
go
[Applause]
well thank you very much and on behalf
of Melania myself and our entire family
I want to thank you all for being here
tonight's very special occasion at a
very special place
you and all of those watching are the
heart and soul of this incredible
movement and the greatest country in the
history of the world it's very simple
there's never been anything
like it
this great movement of ours never been
anything like it and perhaps there will
never be anything like it again there's
never been anything to compete with what
we have all done
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests and
my fellow citizens America's comeback
starts right now
foreign
two years ago when I left office the
United States stood ready for its golden
age our nation was at the Pinnacle of
power prosperity and Prestige towering
above all rivals vanquishing all enemies
and striding into the future confident
and so strong
in four short Years everybody was doing
great men women
African-Americans Asian Americans
Hispanic Americans everybody was
thriving like never before
there was never a time like this we
turned the page on Decades of globalist
sellouts and one-sided trade deals
lifted Millions out of poverty and
together we built the greatest economy
in the history of the world
when the virus hit our Shores I took
decisive action and saved lives and the
U.S economy and by October of the same
year America was roaring back with the
number one fastest economic recovery
ever recorded how about that
all of the incoming Administration and
all they had to do was just sit back and
watch
inflation was non-existent our Southern
border was by far the strongest ever
and because the Border was so tight
drugs were coming into our country at
the lowest level in many many years
importantly after Decades of rising
energy costs the United States had
finally attained The Impossible Dream of
American Energy Independence which soon
would have turned into energy dominance
for the first time in memory China was
reeling and
back on its heels you've never seen that
before
because the United States was outdoing
them on every single front and China was
paying billions and billions of dollars
in taxes and tariffs the farmers know
that because they got 28 billion of it
no president had ever sought or received
one dollar
for our country from China until I came
along and we were getting hundreds of
billions of dollars
many people think that because of this
China played a very active role in the
2020 election just saying just saying
there we go sure that didn't happen
instead of jobs and factories leaving
America for China they were for the
first time ever leaving China for
America
businesses were pouring back because of
our historic tax and regulation cuts the
biggest in both categories in history
bigger even than what Ronald Reagan was
able to produce and he produced a lot
China Russia Iran and North Korea were
in check
and respect it they respected the United
States and quite honestly they respected
me I knew them well
The Vicious Isis caliphate which no
president was able to conquer was
decimated by me and our great warriors
in less than three weeks and al-baghdadi
its founder was hunted down and killed
North Korea had not launched
North Korea had not launched a single
long-range missile since my Summit with
chairman Kim Jong-un nearly three years
before we developed a relationship and
that's a good thing not a bad thing it's
a good thing
very good thing actually because look at
what's happening today
my opponents made me out to be a
warmonger
and just a terrible person who would
immediately go into war
they said during the 2016 campaign that
if he becomes president there will never
be a war within weeks and we will have
wars like you've never seen before
it will happen immediately and yet
I've gone decades decades without a war
the first president to do it for that
long a period
here here
the wiggle fingers
America was prospering and our country
was on track for an amazing future
because I made big Promises to the
American people and unlike other
presidents I kept my promises I kept
I like it so far this is good
good stuff
foreign
thank you very much
under our leadership we were a great and
glorious Nation something you haven't
heard for quite a long period of time
we're a strong nation and importantly we
were a free Nation
but now we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation for millions of
Americans the past two years under Joe
Biden have been a time of pain hardship
anxiety and despair
as we speak inflation is the highest in
over 50 years gas prices have reached
the highest levels in history and expect
them to go much higher now that the
Strategic National reserves which I
filled up have been virtually drained in
order to keep gasoline prices lower just
prior to the election
Joe Biden has intentionally surrendered
our energy Independence there is no
longer even a thought of dominance and
we are now begging for energy help from
foreign Nations many of whom find us
detestable
our Southern border has been erased and
our country is being invaded by millions
and millions of Unknown People many of
whom are entering
for a very bad and Sinister reason
and you know what that reason is
we will be paying a big price for this
Invasion into our country for years to
come
hundreds of thousands of pounds of
deadly drugs
including very lethal fentanyl are
flooding across the now open and totally
poorest Southern border
the blood-soaked streets of our once
great cities our cesspools are violent
crimes which are being watched all over
the world as leadership of other
countries explained that this is what
America and democracy is really all
about how sad
the United States has been embarrassed
humiliated and weakened for all to see
the disasters in Afghanistan perhaps the
most embarrassing moment in the history
of our country
where we lost lives left Americans
behind and surrendered 85 billion
dollars worth of the finest military
equipment anywhere in the world
and Ukraine which would have never
happened if I were your president or
something
I agree I don't think we I don't think
the Ukraine thing would happen if Trump
was president
and even the Democrats admit that that's
something I've seen them admit over and
over again
but our enemies are speaking of us with
scorn and laughter and derision because
of
those two events
but there are many more even just today
a missile was sent in probably by Russia
to Poland 50 miles into Poland yeah and
people are going absolutely wild and
crazy and they're not happy they're very
very angry
now we have a President Who falls asleep
at Global conferences
was held in contempt by the British
Parliament over Afghanistan
thanks to the
words of wisdom he said thank you to the
wrong country for inviting him to a
major Summit on the environment of all
things
how long do you think until days to get
formerly announces
the country well well since they spoiled
it when they said the next president
when they introduced oh that's a good
point
they basically already announced it
unimaginable spoiler alert Too Short
years ago
yeah yeah I wanna I wanna I wanna just
stress everybody was listening that you
should probably renew New Deal we can't
just play Trump speaking without doing a
show ourselves for a variety of reasons
yeah is all you know so we can't just
talk about and yet nuclear weapons which
would I don't want to interrupt right
right I mean he was he was as a Raymond
g Stanley Jr just said Trump's rolling
hard 20s so I'm like I'm reluctant to
chime in but it's 1 8 of an inch for us
I have questions already if you guys
wanna
does not have to be this way let's hear
it
surrender in Afghanistan was pointed at
Union
two years ago we were a great nation and
soon we will be a great nation again
that's what I wanted to hear
the decline of America is being forced
Upon Us by Biden and the radical left
lunatics running our government right
into the ground this decline is not a
fate we must accept when given the
choice boldly clearly and directly I
believe the American people will
overwhelmingly reject the left's
platform of national ruin and they will
embrace our platform of national
greatness and glory to America Glory
he's nailing it
I want to hear that Maga exactly one
week ago our citizens voted in the
important midterm elections and despite
a ridiculously long and unnecessary
period of waiting far longer in fact
than any third world country just a
short time ago the Republicans won back
control of the House of Representatives
not necessarily but most likely we don't
know yet right and it was with a great
Trump endorsed candidate Congressman
elect Kevin they're one seat away highly
yeah who is a fantastic person
a fantastic person
[Applause]
and I'm very happy it was his vote
that did it but we so we now won back
this happened just an hour ago much
criticism is being placed on the fact
that the Republican Party should have
done better and frankly much of this
blame is correct
but the citizens of our country have not
yet realized the full extent and gravity
of the pain our nation is going through
and the total effect of the suffering is
just starting to take hold they don't
quite feel it yet but they will very
soon I have no doubt that by 2024 it
will sadly be much worse and they will
see much more clearly what happened and
what is happening to our country and the
voting will be much different and
fetterman and Senate that is true it's
going to get really bad financially in
the United next year next year
absolutely especially with energy
especially in Europe especially
International are you getting ready yeah
he sounds tired man it's not the same
guy he sounds more reserved yeah he's
doing wispy voice no he's doing he's
doing it right I do want to point out
that in terms my endorsement success
rate was
232 wins and only 22 losses you don't
hear that
from the media how much do you bench
and an elegant press place and I'm not
going to use the term fake news media
this is going to be something so we're
going to keep oh man we it's been two
it's been too long I hear that from the
media
but I think you will because people are
starting to see what happened that's
some score and in the primaries was 98.6
percent
but they were still trying to blame me
and the reason for physics yes and that
unprecedented success rate is that the
Trump Administration changed our nation
on trade on securing the border with the
strongest safest border ever in the
history of our country on Islamic
terrorism we had
practically just about not that I can
think of no Islamic attacks terrorist
attacks during the Trump Administration
and in fact we got along very well with
the various countries
including coming up with the Abraham
Accords it's a big thing Abraham I bet
most those people don't know what they
are but it's because of cutting taxes
at the highest level ever
and on building the greatest economy
anytime in the history of the world
there's never been an economy like we
had just two years ago
despite the outcome in the Senate we
cannot lose hope and we must all work
very hard for a gentleman and a great
person named Herschel Walker a fabulous
human being who loves our country and
will be a great closed caption United
States Senator notice how the captioning
comes before he says it for her show and
he deserves oh I wanted to run on a
delay Will Chamberlain says low energy
not 2016 Trump that's what I was just
saying he sounds tired he's just old
reserved he's old we're elected
is very descriptive
I think this is the demeanor he needed
to take in the popular vote another
thing that's not discussed for the house
we must remember that Republicans won
watching um
more votes the largest margin in many
many
years
five million with almost one voice are
like breaking the great words
reporting
let me let me let me double check real
quick
one man's not going to solve all of your
problems that's important to understand
well in one office that's what I'm
worried about people putting all their
faith into the political Insider reports
decision desk has confirmed Republicans
have the house there we go Victory
should we crack the Louis Again by 40
seats so let's win
by two seats be happy
but she's on her way to another country
right now she's but you know that's
that's fire you know exactly what the
challenge is is it that but we always
know if you have this was not the end in
a political it was only the beginning of
our fight to rescue the American Dreams
right then what does that say that
yeah it's American dream and that's that
I think that was not good what he did
all right
going to Idaho and saying I got to throw
it to Luke Luke said that Trump was
going to draw it out and not announce
immediately and he was right in order to
make America great and glorious again I
thought he'd come out right away and say
it I'm not counting this he's going to
build us up they did say it though but
he didn't he's going to Crescendo it and
build up and then at the end just like
hit it
play Tiny Dancer he was on time which is
also impressive because he's usually
always late to his house what's going on
I think you just did it or are you guys
are just about to you got Tiny Dancer
I'm gonna say eye of the tiger what
they're gonna lead out with what's YMCA
YMCA
that'd be a good one
so many incredible friends and family
here tonight it's such a beautiful thing
it's a lot of people say how do you
speak before so many people all the time
if when there's love in the room it's
really easy if you want to know
you
ought to try it sometime
together we will be taking on the most
corrupt forces and entrenched interests
imaginable our country is in a
horrible state where he did just
announce it this is not a task for a
politician or a convention you're busy
talking sorry guys what a great movement
whoops that embodies the courage
confidence and the spirit of the
American people this is a movement this
is not for
any one individual this is a job this
money as I was saying she was going to
draw it out he was literally people
working together from all across the
land and from all walks of life young
and old black and white Hispanic and
Asian many of whom we have brought
together for the very very first time if
you look at the numbers if you look at
what's happened with Hispanic with
African-American with Asian and just
look at what's happening this is a party
that has become much bigger much
stronger
much more powerful can do much more good
for our country orange man's job foreign
we can't stay quiet any longer you're
angry about what's happening to our
country our country is being destroyed
before your very eyes
working parent
for every entrepreneur and under
appreciated police officer who is ready
to shout for perspective in our
particular issues he was running uh
about whether or not Texas would be
leaving I talk about it in the book and
he said no no Texas won't leave because
this will not be my campaign people are
people are pointing out uh real uh
felani says I mean it's not like it
doesn't say Trump 2024 and his lectern
for the entire speech
[Laughter]
massive corruption we are up against is
you the American people it's true the
American people the greatest people on
Earth we love them all well there you go
and we love both he's definitely going
to win the nomination there's nothing no
one in there I got to say it right now
we I you know we're we're all sitting
here talking about Ron DeSantis but I
gotta admit when you see Trump get up
there Milo's right all of a sudden it's
like I can't imagine DeSantis going up
against strong I feel like we got to
help him at this point I don't I love
politics but we do need a better country
and a better way I would never speak to
this you're saying Help Trump yes we
just didn't help ourselves
no Trump's convinced them you know I
mean I'm not convinced I want to see
them on a debate stage I want to see
them duke it out I want to see it I want
to see the best idea wins I want to see
the best candidate win like real help
like get here in person point out his
flaws to his face humiliate him let him
humiliate me like be a real person kind
of help that's what we need to do
together and we were doing that that was
not just blindly supported because the
success was greater than this country
has ever had we were LeapFrog in China
and leap frogging everybody else and
everybody wanted a piece of it
Milo was right
but just as I promised in 2016 I am your
voice I am your voice
oh man I am so excited the Washington
establishment wants to silence us but we
will not let them do that
what we have built together over the
past six years is the greatest movement
in history because it is not about
politics it's about our love for this
great country America and we're not
going to let it fail
I am running because I believe the world
has not yet seen the True Glory of what
this nation can be we have not reached
that Pinnacle believe it or not
in fact we can go very far we're going
to have to go far first we have to get
out of this ditch and once we're out
you'll see things that nobody imagined
for any country
it's called the United States of America
and it's an incredible place
we are Americans and we do not have to
endure what has taken place in
Washington D.C this is our country our
government and the corridors of power or
our their our Carters they're not their
Carters these are our Carters
and we are
coming to take those Carters back
we have uh Brie Sullivan says Ian Les
Mis isn't about the French Revolution
it's about the June Rebellion
of 1832 he picked that song because of
the populist message of freedom
look how fast it's all going I will
fight like no one has ever six years
before
we will defeat the radical left
Democrats that are trying to destroy our
country from within and likewise protect
us all we want to protect us we have to
be protected really though from all of
those Nations out there that are looking
to destroy us from Beyond air Shores
there are lots of Nations that hate us
Gravely
and that's the problem when they look at
us and disarray like we are right now
when we go to them begging for oil and
we have more Liquid Gold under our feet
than they have or any other nation has
and we don't use it because we're going
to them it's crazy what's happening we
can't let it continue Joe Biden is the
face of left-wing failure and Washington
corruption he had a big G20 dinner
tonight everybody flew over to wherever
they flew over and guess what he never
showed up they're still looking for him
he's off book now yeah
like you wouldn't believe it was one
give me the next one give me the next
one and we got him to stop taking
advantage of our countries Every Nation
took advantage of her he's better off
than he is when he's scripted last time
he got elected day one we went on script
and he was on script the entire time it
was really just Discerning I thought he
was going to be off book Trump like just
going full Kennedy but because we did a
great job manufacturers also and we did
a deal we restructured
we restructured our terrible deal with
terrible deal with Japan and I did it
with prime minister ABI a great man who
unfortunately is so sad he was a great
friend of mine but a great man loved his
country so much but we restructured and
made it a really terrific deal and with
right now there are several ngos antifa
type groups that are convening and
probably began convening yesterday
and they're getting funding they're
gearing up we're going to see extreme
violence like we saw the day Donald
Trump was inaugurated they went around
DC burning things down setting fire to
Vehicles lighting garbage in the streets
smashing windows I hope you all are
ready for what this means you mean that
you mean just so we're clear you're
talking about those mostly peaceful
protests mostly peaceful okay just
making sure we're thinking about the
same thing
could not take that and I say that not
in laughter I say that in tears our
country could not take four more years
it can only take so much
it's all very fragile to start off with
it can only take so much see that line
in 2020 I received the largest number of
votes in any sitting president and it's
unwanted by a lot and we will do it
again but with even more votes what he
said he has effectively reinforced some
of the some of the sentiments that we
were talking about earlier
leads to the skepticism than one guy one
officer great people very
entrepreneurial people two and a half
the wall and they thought oh that would
hurt me with the Hispanic vote no it
helped me because they understood they
wanted safety they wanted security and
they understood the Border better than
anybody else all right so uh what do you
guys say he's he's going off the script
he made the announcement should we get
into Super chats yeah I don't know when
he's lying that's the problem it all
sounds great and I'm makes me feel good
a lot of stuff but I don't know if he's
lying because like you just said he said
the Border was the strongest it's ever
been in his presidency you're from Texas
specifically said he was Lie it wasn't
yeah okay so did it improve some sure
but was it the strongest ever probably
not no I mean when you understand the
escalation of the Border crisis and how
long it's gone on it was not at levels
that it is at right now so granted if
you were to take a snapshot say of the
last 10 years and say you know was it
better yeah I mean across some measures
it was better you know he was able to to
do some Razzle Dazzle and vote title 42
to immediately Deport right instead of
Catch and Release to immediately Deport
which federal court over overturned
today by the way I want to say to
everybody
um many many who tuned in specifically
to watch the announcement we're gonna
we're gonna go to super chats but I want
to stress when we started this show I
said I didn't want to hear about the
past in the sense of like oh it was
stolen from me I wanted to hear about
making America great Trump did exactly
that now he said I'm gonna make America
great but he didn't know he talked about
unemployment he talked about not
starting any wars those things I really
liked he talked about how Biden failed
with the Afghanistan surrender I like
what he said here's what I did that was
good here's what's happening that's bad
and he didn't come out and say it was
mine it was my and it was taken from me
I that that's what I don't want to hear
and he didn't do that he came out very
very serious with and and and and you
know like Will Chamberlain mentioned low
energy but I think that's on purpose
other people are commenting that Trump
at his rallies is same as he's always
been high energy you know feisty and all
that stuff and I've seen some of them so
I agree I am happy to see him coming up
making making this announcement on the
core things that America needs to do to
be better
like I was saying that's what I want to
see and and we see it so I'm happy he's
still not done though so we're gonna see
what else he said I'm gonna watch the
speech just just to get a full
understanding of it but we'll we'll come
back to it we'll keep it we'll keep it
rolling and just plain common sense it's
common sense
[Applause]
in two years the Biden Administration
has destroyed the U.S economy there's
the other people with Victory we will
again build the greatest economy ever
platitude will take place quickly we
will build the greatest economy but he
didn't zero detail but he did no he was
at the house we were inflating it the
fastest it's ever been inflated he spent
a lot of money before car wrote a lot of
money handed off and indebted this
country the stock market was higher than
just prior to covet coming in and we did
it twice and we will do it again but
this time we'll do it bigger stronger
better than anybody can even imagine
let's see it
all I need is a design plan
[Applause]
and one of the beautiful things of the
pause if there is such a thing is a
beautiful thing but one of the the
important factors of the pause is that
we see how bad they've done
so we will be able to do it properly and
it will be much easier everybody will
agree with us because everybody sees
what a bad job has been done during this
two-year period and it will be a
four-year period everybody sees that it
will be much easier for us to do what
has to be done behind the scenes he
better go after ballot harvesting or at
least build that if he wants to win yes
we will immediately tackle inflation and
bring down to a level that it was you
know we were at zero but actually the
best number is one percent do you know
that you don't want it really zero
you're but we've we were at zero we
actually got it to exactly one percent
the perfect number one thing every
Economist agrees don't have it to have
it like at one percent they even say one
to two but I said let's do one and we
had that one percent and we got it there
for a long period of time and we had wow
the value of it was gonna be so much fun
so that this country could make a lot of
money and I thought other countries
where they devalued their dollar they've
devalued their currency whether it was
the pound or whether it was the one or
the Yen and I used to fight
like cats and dogs with the leaders of
other countries because they were
stealing from us when they did that they
had artificial devaluations of their
currency it's a very important thing I
haven't even heard it mentioned in two
years that's a very important thing it's
very hard
for us to compete when they do that
artificially and they had to pay a big
price when they did it and they never
really did it for very long I said we're
not going to do business with you
anymore as a country and they believed
me
Joseph said super chats can pound sand
just as the Biden Administration has
done very very openly and bravely
because I can't imagine saying let's put
America last I think it takes courage
we will again put America first
you're here
every policy
thank you very much
we do love our country isn't it that's
why we're here
I didn't need this I had a very nice
easy life it's uh this is something I
didn't need and a lot of you people
don't need either but we love our
country we have to take care of our
country we have to save our country
country every policy
must be geared toward that which
supports the American worker the
American family and businesses both
large and small and allows our country
to compete with other nations on a very
Level Playing Field which we never had
until I came along and the Trump
Administration came along and now we're
losing it they're moving back into China
they're moving back into these other
countries it's horrible
that means low taxes low regulations and
fair trade much of which I've already
completed
but now we'll even greatly enhance other
countries should pay for the privilege
of coming into the American Marketplace
they have to pay to come into our
country and make all of that money take
it away from us and thanks to the Trump
Administration still the best and the
biggest
country in the world is what we have we
have the best and the biggest if you
remember for many years you can look in
your projection books China was going to
take over from us as the largest economy
in the world in 2018 or 2019 I said I
don't like that timing
and I was with
president XI who's now president for
life
I call him King he said no no I'm not
the king I said yes you are the king
you're president for life it's the same
thing
but I said president president you can't
do these things you can't remember they
had a China 25 that means China was
going to take over virtually the whole
world economy by 25 I said that's not a
nice sign I don't want that sign they
took it down they took down the whole
slogan probably will be coming back at
some point in the near future
but I found it very insulting I said I
find that very insulting on day one we
will end Joe Biden's war or an American
Energy oh yeah
and you will see when that happens you
will see energy costs come down and
because energy is so big and so
important you will see inflation
dropping dropping dropping dropping you
will see it come down it's a thing of
beauty and you wouldn't think it's that
complicated now what has been
complicated a little bit is what's
happened to so many other things I
believe originally started by this
energy disaster
we were a dollar 87
a gallon for gasoline and now it's
sitting five six seven and even eight
dollars and it's going to go really bad
the Socialist disaster known as the
Green New Deal which but that's partly
because demand was near zero during
coven but the average I think during his
presidency was like 2 30. so it is still
really really good so that our country
can be way better than the business and
grow and Thrive like it should
yeah gas went negative during covet
right if they remember they were paying
to give it away that's crazy
[Applause]
Germany tried it you know Germany tried
it they were up for about a year
remember I sent to
Angela remember Angela do you remember
Uncle nobody's remembering her now
Angela Merkel I sent her
a white flag of surrender she said but
why but why do you send this to me
Donald
I said Angela
you're getting 78 of your energy from
Russia and when that happens history has
proven that it's not good for Germany
just take a look over the last 150 years
it hasn't been good what I didn't know
would take place so fast and Germany
closed as you know all of its Coal Power
oh dude clear plants everything and I
gotta pull-ups and tweets plants and
they're building them fast and China's
building a coal plant every week every
week they open up another and then they
talk about all of the things that they
do environmentally they are watching us
die with the green new deal with our
windmills and with our solar that
doesn't have the power to fire up our
great factories and our great plants
they are watching us die and they're
laughing as it happens remember CNN cut
off Trump's audio and it's just doing
commentary now National Security and
that's what it is we need economic
Atomic security the energy crisis
launch an all-out campaign to eliminate
America's dependence on China I mean
we'll bring our supply chains which are
a disaster right now
good luck getting a turkey for
Thanksgiving look at this look at this
let me let me let me show you guys this
uh I want to show you some of the media
reactions we will bring our supply
chains and look at this manufacturing
base back home as we were strongly doing
during the Trump Administration and we
will systematically bring back wealth
health and success to the American
middle class and to America it says uh
Donald Trump comma who tried to
overthrow the result of the 2020
presidential election and in spite a
deadly right to the Capitol in a
desperate attempt to keep himself in
power comma has filed to run for
president again
we're also hearing Fox cut out his audio
and is also doing commentary over boxes
I heard Fox yeah I thought Fox was just
playing the speech I feel very guilty I
don't want that to happen
everyone's watching their families live
in the Biden economy with inflation
destroying your family and your life
this campaign will be for you help is on
the way Joe Biden has abolished
America's borders we are going to
restore and secure America's borders
just like we had them before best ever
we built the wall
and now we will add to it now we built
the wall we completed the wall and then
we said let's do more and we did a lot
more and as we were doing it we had an
election that came up and when they came
in they had three more weeks to complete
the additions to the wall which would
have been great and they said no no
we're not going to do that and that's
when I realized that they actually want
to have this disaster known as open
borders hard to believe isn't it Reddit
libertarian one of the reasons so much
from The Washington Post Trump who has
the president fomented an Insurrection
said he's running again Mexico to give
us free of charge 28 000 soldiers right
in your evening with all the journalists
freaking out Mexico is a great Gentleman
by the way socialist but that's okay
he's a great man and a great friend of
mine but 28 000 soldiers while we were
building the wall and then when the wall
was finished you know that's how we set
all these records the corporate media is
like this is horrible this is the end of
the Democracy yes I have a job yes so I
finally have something to do people
coming in not three or four million
people they're pouring into our country
we have no idea who they are and where
they come from we have no idea it's
interesting because I'm watching
poisoning I'm watching a lot within
moments of my inauguration because I'm
catching obviously
remain in Mexico
MSNBC cut it out they're not even
showing any of it remain in Mexico which
was so important everybody came in here
you know honestly if you think about it
MSNBC would probably show it on one
screen remain in Mexico
on the other side of the screen
they stay and we have no idea where they
are they get lost
and it's very dangerous for our country
and again I'll say we're going to pay a
big price someday for what they're not
wrong quick announcement though Biden
said that it's unlikely that missile
that hit Poland was Russian yeah the
Polish president is also saying similar
things out into our countries we have no
choice we have no choice
[Applause]
stop the flow of deadly drugs and
horrible you know why they do that
though
which both have been they're looking at
their their real-time numbers and
they're like okay okay people are
leaving let's start talking or something
maybe
thing it's not ancient because of the
internet human trafficking is worse than
it's ever been in history and we stopped
them at the southern border which is the
number one all over the world like
clockwork all of these woke media
Outlets are are just number one port
unloading on Trump it's at level Vice
news Trump spent years undercutting our
institutions staging attempted to tutor
made in office
one Journal said why why not have run
limits and if they don't want our help
[Laughter]
Stacey Abrams needs a chance
this is amazing the governors and Mayors
are supposed to ask for the help and
they would never ask for the help and
yet people are being shot and killed at
random like nobody's ever seen before
and we sent in the National Guard in
Minneapolis and in other places in
Seattle we went and we were we were
getting ready to go and they took over
part of the city and the governor's the
Democrats don't want to ever ask to do
anything because how long they don't
want to shake things up in the meantime
the cities are rotting his arms indeed
cesspools of blood it was shorts
really short obviously give our police
back their Authority resource escalator
legal protection
[Music]
and I will immediately launch a no holes
bar national campaign to dismantle the
gangs and clean out the nests of
organized Street crime there we go
he's gonna have to deal with the CIA if
he wants to deal with the Fentanyl and
drugs the worst criminals the worst
gangs are MS-13 and under the
Barack Hussein Obama administration they
were unable to take them out because
they're countries where they came from
wouldn't take them and I learned about
that and my first day I actually say but
I learned about it and I said which
countries and it was Honduras and
Guatemala it was El Salvador some others
and I said how much do we pay them sir
you pay them
750 million dollars a year it's a lot of
money
I said all right stop payment we're not
paying them anymore because they
wouldn't accept them they would put
planes
look at this one with these gang members
from
journalist Emily a well-crafted tweet
The Washington Post wrote the twice
impeached former president Donald Trump
76 who refused to concede the 2020
election and as a subject of multiple
criminal investigations is running again
in 2024 increasing the likelihood of a
potential rematch of fighting countries
amazing and I got to know all of the
presidents and prime ministers I got to
know them all and I said all right stop
payment of the 750 million dollars a
year they won't take them and you could
not get anybody back in because they
sent them out they didn't just come out
they sent them out they don't want the
bad ones they want to keep their good
ones they don't want the bad ones these
are gang members that will kill and they
like using knives because a knife is
more painful
than a gun you've read the stories Ms so
so how do you think they're going to
twist what he's saying they're gonna
they're gonna say he's racist he accused
people of being animals again
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wants to get them four billion dollars
they were happy with 750 and now they
want to give them four billion dollars
somebody someday is going to explain
that one to me it actually
makes you Rage with anger when you hear
that they wanted 750 so badly and now
they're getting four billion dollars we
will wage war upon the cartels and stop
the Fentanyl and deadly drugs from
killing two hundred thousand Americans
per year
and I will ask Congress for legislation
ensuring that drug dealers and human
traffickers these are human terrible
terrible horrible people the CIA who are
responsible for death Carnage and crime
all over our country every drug dealer
during his or her life on average will
kill 500 people with the drugs they sell
not to mention the destruction of
families
but we're going to be asking everyone
who sells drugs gets caught selling
drugs to receive the death penalty for
their heinous acts that is insanity
because not every drug is the same it's
just like the Philippines
any more Blue Ribbon
committees we don't need I don't like to
say this and I don't even know of the
American public I wonder where he gets
numbers on that like why why is it a
good idea please don't say that sir
that's not nice they kill 500 people
each on average
and if you don't do this in China when I
was with President XI I said president
do you have a drug problem no no no no
no we don't he looked at me like I
didn't know what I was doing
he said no we don't have a drug how come
you don't have a drug problem he said
quick trial what is a quick trial quick
I sort of knew what is a quick trial
that's where if you get caught dealing
drugs you have an immediate and quick
trial and by the end of the day you're
executed nope we don't want to be like
China can we please not be like the
totalitarian China literally in his
announcement he's like I'm going to
create a policy off the Communist
challenge
it's authoritarian it used to be called
out and criticized again we were
stopping it that was way down that
number but they send it in but they
don't have a drug problem
of course they have a drug problem
there's no drug problem no drug you ask
them you got to end them
he'll tell you for all the China stop
the CIA from Shipping in the drugs and
stop the war on drugs and then we would
have less harm we wouldn't have all
these problems but no we got to be like
totalitarian China that's crazy and
nobody even cares they can do whatever
they want to do and become rich it's a
disgrace so if you want to get rid of
that and also bring down your level of
crime probably 75 or 80 percent
that's the only answer no more Blue
Ribbon I refuse to create them anymore
that was just a joke it was New York
people wanting to be on a committee for
publicity reasons no no more Blue Ribbon
committees that's the only way you're
going to solve the problem and
I hope politicians are listening because
they should do it quickly Joe Biden has
also proven that he is committed to
indoctrinating our children even using
the Department of Justice against
parents who object it's a terrible thing
it's happened it's so sad what's
happening
when I'm in the white house our schools
will cease pushing critical race Theory
as they were
this is why Elon wanted to buy Twitter
because he knew Trump made it worth a
lot of money and yes it's true Twitter
almost went under before Trump started
or if they do that they will lose all
federal funding but we'll get them just
interesting he makes critical race yeah
and I will be the president to finally
fix this education in America we were
doing most of the legislation state
level they will address it and of course
as an example participants
no men that's not a that's not a
particularly Grand promise other than
you know what he could say is let's get
the federal government out of education
and that would fix things yeah right
that would be something and the
Department of Education Politically
Incorrect to say I said that's okay I'll
say it anyway if you don't mind
we've had we've had tremendous
tremendous problems and and you know
it's very unfair to women just very very
unfair we will defend the rights of
parents and we will defend the family as
the center of American Life there we go
that's what I said right I want him to
hate the guy sitting with the newspaper
and mom's got iced tea come on standing
up make America great again 10 years ago
so he should have got to that much
earlier in the speech probably before he
started saying look I'm using the
Communist counties but I guess that's
what I am
I hate that thought but that a
politician would be up saying we will
defend parental rights of course you can
offend to who would think that we even
have to mention this who would think it
even should be a subject to be talked
about we have to defend parental rights
can you believe this
as commander-in-chief
I will get Biden's radical Jeb Bush
tweeted what a low energy speech by
Donald I did and in the first day they
put it down but he signed an executive
that's like Richard Simmons calling you
a crappy dresser we will abolish every
Biden covet mandate and rehire every
patriot who was fired from our military
with an apology and full background I
don't know this the China has zero covid
so you should I just want that I want
you all to understand
Twitter is back
and Donald Trump is running it's going
to be a meme magic meme War like we saw
back in 2015 2016. you're going to be
laughing non-stop all day and everything
I'm ready for this possibly getting us
into World War III which can seriously
happen I will keep America out of
foolish and unnecessary Foreign Wars
just as I did for four straight years
non-interventionist foreign policy I
mean that's something we will again have
peace through strength that's all it is
as events overseeds have shown
to protect our people from the
unthinkable threat of nuclear weapons
and Hypersonic missiles the United
States must also build a
state-of-the-art Next Generation missile
defense Shield we need it the power of
these missiles and the power of a word
that I refuse to say
nuclear
we have to have it we need a defense
shield and we have to do it and we
actually have the technology and we're
going to build it just as I rebuilt our
military I will get this done I rebuilt
our entire military which nobody talks
about more money for the military
industrial complex when I got there we
had jet fighters that were 48 years old
Jeb runs we had bombers that was sick I
hope he does too I want Jeff Corral
please clap oh yeah and now the
grandchild you should get a shirt made
with that on it and make fun of himself
yeah but from within none is greater
than the weaponization of trump wasn't
wrong I mean that guy that guy is uh he
elicits the sort of excitement top to
bottom overhaul to clean out the
festering rod and Corruption of
Washington D.C
yeah
remember when Biden said he was going to
stop Trump
he would use constitutional legal
authority to prevent him from taking
power
yo it's gonna get lit well let's see
let's see how that goes out I'd like to
see how that plays out
because honestly all they do when they
when they attempt to screw at him that
way is they just validate his position
people are pointing out he said the
quick and quick trial execution is a
terrible thing what China was doing I
will tell you
Christopher
Steele who wrote the fake desier
if he will lie and say that the fake
dossier
was true
and he refused to do it
so it had to be really fake
and then they hired somebody
timchenko for two hundred thousand
dollars a year to focus on Trump and to
get Trump and other things including the
raid of a very beautiful house that sits
right here
the rate of Mar-A-Lago think of it
and I say why didn't you raid Bush's
Place why didn't you rate Clinton
32 000 emails why didn't you rate
Clinton's place what and you do
Obama who took a lot of things with him
we will dismantle the Deep State and
restore government by the people
full back pain of people kicked out of
the military over the vax mandates to
further drain the swamp I will push for
a constitutional amendment to impose
term limits on members of Congress it's
time okay he's definitely been listening
to us our people that come on the show
term limits for bureaucrats
and I will ask for a permanent ban on
taxpayer funding of campaigns a lifetime
ban on lobbying by former members of
Congress oh yeah there we go
no I see what they make they leave
the White House or they leave Congress
and they're paid millions and millions
and millions of dollars a year now you
have to have a ban
we want to ban on members of Congress
getting rich by trading stocks with
Insider information yes
Pelosi you're fired many of our great
members agree with that they actually
agree with that and of course we will do
whatever it takes to bring back honesty
confidence and Trust in our elections
to eliminate
I will immediately demand voter ID same
day voting here we go
there it is what would that do
a paper ballots
stone tablets
only paper ballots there you go
nonsense nope that's exactly what we
just say I saw D when he saw an R you
can lie and there's four people watching
when all four of them come alive that's
right all four of them can lie even
though they're competing against each
other
10 o'clock in the evening no complaints
they're not really competing yeah they
absolutely are the Republicans and the
Democrats Trump
are not the same as neocon establishment
Republicans no complaints
unless they destroy it it's there to
check always right now it's like what do
you do do you audit the code and then
who lets you do it it's proprietary a
box full of documents is publicly owned
and you and and they can go in and say I
want to open the box again who's there
though you can't if you can file a
lawsuit yeah I mean you shouldn't have
to do that you just click a button that
2019 white paper
everybody
because literally they came out and they
said all of these questions every single
solitary one of them
and they said here are the two things
paper ballots risk we'll get that job
done making sure they're going through
this he's talking about fixing the
election process
but this is just the beginning of our
national greatness agenda and that's
what we call it a national greatness
agenda our country can be greater than
it ever was our country was great our
country's not great anymore our
countries are laughing stock right now
but our country can be greater than it
ever was before by a lot there will be
more much more to come
in the months ahead there are so many
things we can do many of them are not
even hard to implement the journey ahead
of us will not be easy anyone who truly
seeks to take on this rigged and corrupt
system will be faced with a storm of
fire that only a few
could understand right
I happen to have some children in the
first they they understand
in fact
my one boy stand up Eric
e-bones
is the new enough Ivanka and Jared are
there
I think yeah
maybe oh it was in the middle so unfair
that was unfair Al Capone was a great
gangster Al Capone got far less
Billy the Kid got almost done
he was killing me James now
PhD in subpoenas they come from Congress
they
and I appreciate the job you do and the
abuse that you've taken I really do
[Applause]
and it hasn't been a joyride for our
great first lady either
it hasn't been a joy rug stand up on it
we need to see more accordion hands
I go home and she says they do love her
I go home and she says you look angry
and upset I said just leave me alone I
got
hasn't been the easiest thing but she's
been a great first lady and people love
her
[Applause]
we will be resisted by the combined
forces of the establishment the media
the special interests the globalists the
Marxist radicals the woke corporations
oh man weaponized power of the federal
government the Colossal political
machines the tidal wave of dark money
and the most dangerous domestic
censorship system
ever created by man or woman the most
dangerous system we've ever had we will
be attacked we will be slandered we will
be persecuted just as I have been I mean
I have been but many people in this room
have been
but we will not be intimidated we will
persevere we will stand tall in the
storm
we will March forward into the torrent
and we in the end will win our country
will win we will win
my fellow Americans we will join
together and reverse this staggering
American Decline and it is staggering
indeed and we will again restore the
spirit of our nation and then we must
build and raise up a legacy that will
stand without equal
in the entire history of the world with
your help we will create communities
where our children will grow up safe and
strong and a nation where they will grow
up free prosperous and well
we will re-establish the principles of
hard work and Merit and end the scourge
of homelessness that is plaguing our
beleaguered democrat-run cities we will
heal our divisions and bring our people
back together through incredible success
we will defend life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness we will expand the
frontiers of human knowledge and extend
the horizons of human achievement it's a
funny meme it's a it's an it's a a flow
chart should you run for the Republican
nomination is your name Rhonda status or
Donald Trump yes or no and yes go for it
no don't embarrass yourself he looks
like he's finishing up here everyone
involved we need everyone's help we need
to look out for one another we need to
be friends and we need every Patriot on
board
[Applause]
because this is not just a campaign this
is a quest to save our country talking
about saving our country that's right
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much
I am asking for your vote I am asking
for your support and I am asking for
your friendship and your prayers this
very incredible but dangerous Journey
if our movement remains United and
confident then we will shatter the
forces of tyranny and we will unleash
the glories of liberty for ourselves and
for our children and for Generations yet
to come
America's golden age is just ahead
and together
we will make America powerful again
mapa
we will make America wealthy
we will make America strong I'm not
saying that one
we'll make America
proud
we will make America safe again
we will make America glorious it's like
watching a porn
we will make America great again thank
you very much God bless you all thank
you
[Music]
all right that's it good song
orange man back I gotta say I am very
critical of trump he did give the plan
that I was asking for earlier he started
outlining things and he talks about a
lot of really important things about
addressing the voting issues I thought
was very good and talking about the
world at a grand scale about the
military-industrial complex and the I
mean he didn't talk about megacorps and
BlackRock by name but this is the stuff
he's talking about I've never seen I
haven't seen another political candidate
do that maybe Tulsi gabbard I'm excited
because the media is losing their minds
and like
I just I'm kind of resigned to the
nonsense it's a difficult battle you got
to be happy Elon Musk has got Twitter
which means we there's already been
reports that people are coming back that
certain accounts that have long been
banned have been reinstated so we will
see what happens if he brings Trump back
great either way we are going to see the
memes again the memes were so hilarious
with the Pepe frogs and the meme magic
and uh I'm it's you know it's it's
reinvigorating that old six years ago
back back in The Fray it's important
that we look at what was it about 58
minutes into the speech when he said
that he would I thought he said he would
he would arrest drug dealers and in one
day have them tried and executed but I
could be wrong about that people were
saying he commented that he saw he heard
China did that that's not a good thing
but he did call for the execution of
drug dealers yes that I disagree with
completely I don't I don't I think I'm
anti-death penalty I'm not for it and to
take Xi Jinping at his word when he was
like how do you have no drug problems in
China like what an insane thing to say
about your country we have no drug
problems it's like saying we have no
abuse in this country yeah well I I
think what we're going to be seeing in
the next few weeks and months is going
to be an absolute crap show and I'm all
here for it people in the corporate
media are going to be losing their minds
people are going to be just going
absolutely crazy I'm here for all of it
it's going to be a wild ride and man who
knows what's going to happen will
Twitter bring Donald Trump back will he
go back on the platform that's the next
kind of Battlefield that people are
looking at and personally I hope he does
come back to Twitter I think uh this
discourse is going to get wild and
um
put on your seat belts it's going to be
a bumpy ride I found that Trump is I
don't know what's the right word not
susceptible but he's open-minded about
things like if he hears a good idea
he'll start to go with it and then he'll
really go with it if he really believes
in it if he comes so like graphene for
instance or free software two things I'm
really passionate about involving the
United States with being at the
Forefront of I think he could get on
board Edward super chatted Trump cast
Ian is a dirty hippie even though I love
him that is not a lie
I didn't shower today so uh
lots of the nuke idea says
it nuked incredibly important info if
Trump loses the nomination to DeSantis
he may run as a third party splitting
the vote that happened in 1912 with
Roosevelt Taft and Wilson look where
that got us Ross Perot also split the
vote and helped Clinton but uh yeah
we'll see we'll see I don't know for
sure I could see that happening I agree
on the federal level I mean I know I
know in Texas they have a sore loser law
says look if you get bounced out in the
primaries you can't go and run into the
generals right is that is that true yeah
yeah so we had like a situation we had
down there is we had
um
we had a guy named Mark gollaby okay he
ran for comptroller I believe it is he
lost in the primaries but he filed to
run as a as an independent with a
write-in candidacy for uh for the
generals uh as uh for governor right so
that happened so you know there was a
lot of pressure for people when Don
Huffines lost in the primaries and Chad
you know they're like hey you know once
you guys run writing candidates for
files in independent can't do that you
got to sort of lose your law says if you
just bounced out in the primaries you
can't file to run as an independent in
the generals wow I don't know how I feel
about that but that's an interesting
thought it is it is interesting I think
right now uh I don't know how Trump
implements a paper ballot I don't know
how Trump reforms elections I'm glad
he's talking about it because if they're
not thinking about this they lose no
matter what at the very least they
should be gearing up for the Practical
Battle of uh ballot harvesting legal
lawful get out the vote operations
getting low information and low
propensity voters to vote then
do what DeSantis did start cleaning
things up fixing the system and stopping
this rig this ridiculous uh low low
information voter system but we can't
kid ourselves the Republicans don't have
a lot of institutional power to change
things uh right that's why I'm saying
they need to win first and so get that
ballot harvesting how are they what what
are they going to win between now and
2024 that's that's the question in 2024
so right now what they need to do is get
out the vote operations door knocking
campaigns ballot harvesting operations
where it's legal then when they win in
Congress at the state level in the
Senate and the and the federal
government and they get it all in 2024
they start issuing the hard reform
saying you can't do this you can't do
this you can't it's we're done playing
these games well look I I don't want to
let this skate by because I think I
think it'd be a crime if we gloss this
over
if he's talking about you know all of
those election reforms literally things
that we agree with right the paper
ballots you know that all of those
things that he said we do with elections
for that to happen from The Office of
the President
essentially says that he is going to do
the thing that we all castigated Biden
for which is federal you know when Biden
and AOC and the rest ever wanted to
federalize the election system we all
went absolutely you know bat crap crazy
and so for him to carry out the policy
he just suggested he is going to have to
literally do what the what we all
criticize the Democrats for wanting to
do and then just federalize those
elections the next president could just
come in and undo what he did exactly
people are saying I said something I I
don't know what you mean I said
ridiculous that's all I said I didn't
say anything else I said the ridiculous
voting system that's all of course I
don't remember
you know what he didn't mention is
vaccines he glossed over the world
that's not true he didn't say the word
he said that people who who lost their
jobs would be reinstated with an apology
and back pay that's pretty cool that's
amazing he kind of right off the gate
was like and because of me we saved so
many lives during covid and you're like
what is he saying because of you what
because you rushed the vaccine out yeah
look what are you saying right now no
one clapped hop on that bandwagon I'm
not gonna hop on that bandwagon
Administration wrong they sure did his
administration made that that ruling
yeah they empowered I'm gonna undo what
I did come on they they put they gave
Bill Gates a seat at the table right I
mean they all of those lockdowns all
trickled down from the federal side of
this and so I don't think he can I don't
think he can skate by his couple
billions Bill Gates was dictating policy
and telling Trump what to do and Trump
listened and followed his policy and
however you feel about the coveted
vaccines right whatever you feel about
those understand that how you feel about
them is is all the direct result of
operation warp speed which happened
under the Trump Administration so
um you know that's a conversation you
can have all day long about whether or
not his policies are going to be
effective but remember
it's all at the federal level
essentially what they're saying is we're
going to do these things and we're going
to do them hopefully you like them but
that power stays in place for the other
team to be able to do it if you don't
like it is a good one Leland Taylor says
Trump should have ended his announcement
with Elon here's my eight dollars
I just showed like eight dollars like
here you go Elon yeah I got something
for you Elon I'm back baby he had Elon
as an advisor at one point early on and
then Eli was like I'm not working with
that guy yeah he's impossible well Elon
was pushing for more global warming
policies which is also very interesting
and something to keep an eye out because
he wanted more of those policies for
that and allegedly Trump wasn't playing
ball
I really liked that Trump said he was
going to which is crazy declare war on
the cartels like he was saying MI6 is
their biggest enemy that's like
Kennedy's style going after the mob okay
so here's what we do
voter ID no brainer paper ballots of
course same day voting absolutely no
early voting no mail-in voting but
election day is a holiday
how will Democrats give up all the power
and and the way that they established
this game for themselves I don't see
them changing it in any time I see them
holding on to this current position yes
yes you misunderstand I'm not saying
Democrats please give up power I'm
saying this is a policy position he's
running on no different from him saying
I will lower taxes he can't right now
without being in office lower taxes he
needs to win first the election system
needs to be cleaned and fixed so that we
stop having Democrats exploit stupid
people for easy votes and that this
Country Returns to people who care about
it and then it becomes better for
everyone across the board and we can
work to fix these problems that means
right now Republicans need to start
forming organizations and dumping tens
of millions of dollars into get out the
vote and legal ballot harvesting
operations and then when they win they
can pass all the laws they want and
clean the system them up fixing it but
then just really quickly it wasn't uh
MI6 it was MS-13 oh my gosh
intelligence
better story all the stuff
as soon as he said am I six I'm like why
is your name so similar to the cartel
name and what is it M3s
come on guys you gotta diversify because
if I'm getting confused in public that's
that's not that's probably something
that's awesome
they're not going to change the name of
their National Security apparatus
because you made a message Trump is not
going to declare war on MI6 but he
indicated he wanted to declare war on
the cartels MS-13 being one of them guys
guys you know what look it's like all of
this look man all of this who knows
what's going to happen Trump might slip
on a banana peel or something whatever
he might not indicted and if he does
right this is only going to help him
this is the the the the Paradigm that
people need to understand here the
federal government and the corporate
media will go after him which will allow
him to have more popularity so this is
the conundrum that we're dealing with
which I think people should be
questioning that I'm just saying if if
all that happens with Trump is that he
did this today watching the media seethe
is worth it how do you feel about what
Daniel was saying about the
federalization like the federalization
of of voting laws if they if Trump went
in was like I'm gonna make sure that
everyone has to do paper balloting that
up to the states yes and that's why I'm
saying state level it's going to be the
mo like I'm not saying Trump should go
in as the executive and be like I hereby
decree I'm saying Republicans need to
win clean up this system the fact that
Trump is talking about it means they
understand why they're losing it's a
good thing
uh yeah I don't like when Democrats
tried passing that bill that would have
nationalized voting laws very very bad
insane interesting note about that is
when Ted Cruz was asked about he was in
college station when he was asked about
the Texas issue uh he listed
federalization of the elections as one
of his red lines that would cause him he
says look I'm I get it I'm not there yet
but here are some red line issues and he
cited federalization of the elections
elimination Electoral College was
another but he cited that as one of the
triggers for him to support come out and
support Texas he obviously supports our
right to as do many people but
um you know I think I think this
election is a real interesting Flex
point for people you know if you can't
if you can't trust uh that your vote
counts then um will you vote even yeah
well I mean I think look at voter
turnout I mean when you I know in Texas
during the midterms uh voter turnout was
pretty doggone abysmal
um I think it was 60 some odd percent of
people just didn't even vote yeah a lot
of Independents didn't vote a lot of
people who earned involved in politics
didn't vote it was it was around 100
million people that did this country is
made up of about 330 million some of
them children obviously and can't vote
but still a majority of people didn't I
think that was cute that's like when he
was explaining red pill to me earlier I
think right my assessment right now the
economy is bad it was good under Trump
there was it was not perfect but it was
better than it was true um we saw really
great numbers but you guys are right he
was spending a lot there was there was a
lot of money going out but the point is
how does the average American feel and
they certainly don't feel good about
what's happening right now I'm not
convinced that Donald Trump dragged the
midterms I think that's mainstream media
BS look at how they're responding to him
announcing he's running for president if
they really thought he dragged the the
Republican Party Down they'd be saying
Donald Trump who just dragged the
Republicans risks destroying the
Republican party or something like no no
no they're saying he's an
insurrectionist he's old he's he's evil
here's what happened Donald Trump won he
got what 90 success in his endorsements
90s more than that like 93 a lot of
people are trying to claim that he drag
drag to the party down when they just
it's now announced they've won they've
won the House Republicans did it it was
a hard-fought battle where the Democrats
have been operating Under Universal
mail-in ballot rules which is
ridiculously favorable to them due to
Urban density and due to you know ballot
curing and things like that with
Republicans voting in person voting
machines failing they leave the line
it's it's very very difficult for
Republicans plus they it's harder to go
door to door in a rural area than it is
an urban area with that uphill battle
Republicans still got the house and now
I heard today there was a meeting with
fauci and a few other I'm sorry not with
Rand Paul and a few others looking at
inquiries into fauci the coveted
response so this is a good trajectory I
think Donald Trump based on today is on
a strong path and it's looking up a lot
of people on the left are saying look
how low energy and sad he's not going to
win they're nuts
I'm not saying Donald Trump maintains it
for the whole time I'm not saying that
he does better than he did in 2020 you
know 74 million votes or whatever but
I'm saying right now this was the show
of force we needed he did not complain
about about the election he made a joke
about it that was funny but he didn't
waste time talking about it and that's
what that that's what perturbed me in
the past he mentioned strengthening
families he mentioned fixing voting laws
I I'm I dig it let's see let's see let's
see where this goes I think Rodney Santa
is gonna have a very very hard time
going up against Trump after after what
we just saw it was reserved there was a
little bit of humor in there he made a
bunch of good points let's see if he can
maintain that going into this this
primary season I want to see them it's
going to be fun I want to see them I
want to see them I want to see them
argue I want to see them debate ideas I
want to see them go at each other let's
do this I'm so excited we got the new
the new space that we're getting built
right now the new it's a massive
Warehouse like buildings a big steel
building we're gonna have a big
projector with big speakers and a bar
and the new studio is on the second
floor of overlooking the space I'm just
super excited to have this massive
screen playing the debates Ron DeSantis
Donald Trump both of them going at it I
don't know who else could be on that
stage who would even bother trying Jeb
Bush I wish one and only we need them I
would pay now more than ever a few
commentary by Joe Rogan to see Jeb Bush
you know Nikki Haley is going to be
there and Mike Pompeo probably Mike
Pence and I think all of them are going
to get Trump that's the ultimate dude
because they got personal beef I think
this is going to give him a run for his
money I don't think I think I think he's
got he's he might even take it from
maybe I don't think the same should run
I think it's super important that he
that he runs Florida right no matter
what happens like he's such he's so
quality in that position and with Trump
announcing like why would he jab that
like look it's it's the Peter Principle
man you know there's a tendency that we
see somebody have success at a certain
level you know like as governor of a
state someone that we love you know now
they want to just automatically shove
them to an office at that Federal level
and and we have to realize something is
that a lot if you want a politician you
know somebody who's a public servant
Statesman if you want that Statesman to
no longer be a Statesman send them to
work on the federal level right I mean
you know it's like saying hey look we
have this person who's a great swimmer
so let's send them over here to swim in
the Cesspool and they'll they'll make
the Cesspool smell better that's not how
this works I mean you don't you don't do
that and and I think that's and I agree
with you this is part of the problem is
especially the state level you know we
talk about in Texas all the time if our
if our politicians at the state level
couldn't go any higher how much better
would they govern in the state we need
we need to get a a countdown 721 days
until 2024 General so I'd love to get
like a digital clock just put up
counting down in the background every
episode would be hilarious I'm excited
for this let's do it primary season is
going to be so much fun uh the year
after after after a major pres after
presidential election is always like a
downturn everyone's exhausted they're
tired in the political space and then
you get the next year where we're
getting we're getting ready for the
midterms and it's like yeah then finally
we had the midterms happen but now we
enter primary season it is going to be
hilarious Democrats are going to it's
going to look like a sitcom level bad
then you're gonna have Trump I don't
look we don't know if to say this is
going to go for it DeSantis might
actually just say not doing it because
it it could really it could harm his
future prospects but we don't know we
don't know oh I was thinking I'd like to
talk to Candace again I haven't talked
to her since she was on the show last
time and having just gone through she
went through with Trump she said that he
was really rude to her she's no longer
supporting him I'm interested to get her
perspective on on what she thinks about
the speech and she's probably going to
give a recap I guess if you check how to
show the caniso in the show but I just
like to hear her personal her Saga was
pretty interesting I mean she kind of
gave Trump a kind of softball question
about you know the vaccine Trump gave
his answer she didn't even contest them
and then she even released a video
saying Hey guys please go easy on Trump
you know he's a little bit older there
was some fake news by The Daily Beast
and she says that Trump fell for the
fake news by The Daily Beast and that's
why he Trump was mad at her look
what day is the the election in 2024 uh
uh V for Vendetta day is Viva Vendetta
Day
November 5th
2024. the guy fox day is the day now
look guy Fox was a uh a theocrat and I I
think I could be wrong but my
understanding is that he wanted to
install Christian theocracy in the in in
in London and uh you know that was the
Gunpowder Plot or whatever so I read a
little bit about it that this is the guy
Fox mask like V for Vendetta but it's
come to represent whatever that was it
comes it's come to represent Revolution
protest and specifically with V for
Vendetta the people rising up against
the authoritarian establishment
so I'm sure the left is going to come
out and argue the exact same thing we
are the resistance remember remember the
fifth of November we must stop the
fascist Donald Trump the only problem is
Trump's not in power so that analogy
doesn't work as well as the people out
of power saying it to challenge the
machine
but that won't prevent him from trying
no they'll say and they can say because
a legitimate guy so I mean you know
they'll do it they'll try it I'm glad
that Donald uh mentioned the Deep State
I think he said at the words deep state
in the speech because if we're going to
talk about the problem that Society
should be revolting against it's you
know like corporate collusion and stuff
Democratic and Republican freedom is is
came before if corporations existed I
want to give a shout out to Raymond g
Stanley Jr because he's the one who's
pointed out he said Tim remember
remember the fifth of November 2024. so
shout out for that one through Raymond g
oh man is it gonna be fun I'm excited
for this year I'm just I'm just sitting
there I'm I'm thinking about all of the
the primary Democrat debates they're
going to have the weird campaigning the
mud slinging will they debate
each other they have no choice
yeah who's to say well well the well
Biden or whoever becomes the nominee
well here's the thing if Biden says he's
running there's no Democrat primary and
that's just the most ridiculous thing
ever because Biden ain't there no but he
says he's running I know so I wonder if
the age of debates as we know them is
over I would like to see more of them to
people just talking but the moderator
thing like saying I can't talk to you
like me and you Tim are going to debate
we'd be looking at each other asking
each other questions pointing out when
the other person's wrong theorizing
things like that uh the weird debate
they call it a debate but it's like wait
to be called on and answer a question
isn't really a debate so maybe we'll see
more a different format maybe shows like
this will start popping look I paid my
way through college with speech and
debate you know I got I got Hardware at
the house still after all these years uh
what we have are not debates we need
proper debates where these guys are
hammering each other on policy and you
know some would say master uh yes more
master debaters this is what I'm looking
for that's great great yeah all right
everybody so uh this was a a special
episode
um so what I'm going to say is smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're not going to have a members only
segment tonight whenever there's like
longer extended stuff it makes it really
difficult time wise to actually do the
members only segments but of course
there's a huge Library check out the
conversation with Dave Rubin it's
interesting and uh he's great by the way
and uh Miley Annapolis was was also very
great and we're going to what's going on
uh we're going to start sending out cool
little uh knickknacks and things from
the show to people who comment on our
members only content so watch the show
provide a comment and then it's not
really like
um how many times you comment just we're
going to scroll through grab a random
person hit you up and be like hey we're
going to send you something you know
from the show as we're clearing off the
knickknacks that come through we got a
bunch of really interesting interesting
stuff so become a member at timcast.com
you can follow the show at timcastirl on
Instagram follow us there we have Clips
every day you can follow me personally
at timcast basically everywhere follow
me on Instagram and Twitter uh Daniel do
you want to shout anything out you have
a book I hear yeah absolutely uh you
know we didn't get to talk too much
about it tonight thanks Donald
appreciate that uh for your timing he
didn't consult with me by the way but uh
yeah look uh you know we did get a
chance to talk a good bit about Texas
tonight and I would encourage anyone who
uh who has more questions about it uh to
either get the book it's called Texas uh
wine how Texas will leave the union it's
been a four-time bestseller on Amazon uh
or uh you know I would encourage people
to go to our website texitnow.org the
one that Facebook is is putting the
kibosh on uh we have about the 100 most
asked questions about the Texas issue uh
full detailed answers the whole nine
yards and you know the good news is
there's a place for those people there
who if they go there they see what that
they understand what we're doing they
can plug into what we're doing as an
organization and take texit from Theory
into reality so uh very excited about
that and thanks for having me I just
want to point out I got a message from
someone apparently uh our viewership
rivaled Fox News on YouTube that's great
thank you everybody I really do
appreciate it because we're trying to
displace the corporate media even if it
is Fox Bravo and you got to do them by
doing a better job than they do which of
course we strive to do here I strive to
do that on my YouTube channel
youtube.com forward slash we are change
I did a very interesting video about
Klaus Schwab taking over the G20 and
then I did a more spicy video on Luke
uncensored.com but uh just check out the
video right now it's a very interesting
one youtube.com forward slash we are
change see you there and I my mood
actually is elevated after listening to
Donald speak like that I don't agree
with them on there's a lot of things and
I agree with them on some things but the
the fact that he's willing to get up
there and do it and run for president
and say those things is inspiring
because we need more people speaking the
truth or at least speaking their own
perception of the truth we need that now
we need it so thank you Donald for doing
that and everyone else that's involved
with it thanks I care I want to be there
I want to be part of this
yeah
no no I'm not saying I don't adhere to
political parties but I want to support
brilliant genius we got to get you in a
tie-dye Maga Felice hoodie hilarious
bedazzled what we got to do is make one
that says magic make America great Ian
Crossland magic oh it's all in your
hands 100 in your mind yeah
tonight uh it was great to meet you
Daniel tonight was a bunch of fun
um yeah thanks guys
I'm trying to think of a good uh how can
we make make America great and then I
see but not Ian Crossland you know let's
just make a bunch of magic here and sell
it make America gradient Crossing yeah
no but we can come up with something
funny that's like a hip a hippie
pro-trump kind of thing you know all
right everybody thanks for hanging out
uh seriously this has been fantastic I'm
really excited tomorrow's going to be
spicy so you know that tomorrow the
media is going to lose their ever living
ever living mind and we're probably
gonna have a lot to talk about so thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
then bye